okay cars racing I told you I told it
another 90 seconds become there just
like was he laughing bishop so good it
was so good and then he goes vegan again
is it not a draw yeah look how much time
they have you can't just keep are just
capable pick up the increments this is
so great it gorges free mood Wesley
Wesley turns over there's like I think
are you kidding me right now oh my god
that was legendary stuff right there yep
[Music]
[Applause]
I say speech yes you say high speed
chess height I thought championship
speech is high it's a championship game
no this is match this is gonna be this
is gonna be a good day
International Master Danny wrench with
you alongside the one the only Grand
Master Robert Hess we are we are hyped
and this is the speeches championship so
we were both right yeah we're very
excited for these two players that have
come so far and made it all the way to
the top of the bracket as you can see
hit kora Nakamura the overall one seed
against the overall two seed one of the
things that I think hasn't necessarily
been talked about enough is that these
are the top two players if you were
looking at a March Madness bracket this
would have been probably one of the most
predicted possible outcomes in hindsight
given that they're there rapid and blitz
performances in the past tell them that
they're pretty good at what they do
although I love the upset picks and
Alexander Chris Chuck was one of those
under seeded 11c yeah yeah that's true
of course I would have picked him to go
for but Yannick Christophe Duda his
Cinderella story came to a close on
Friday against Wesley so and this is a
pretty great matchup I know people love
a Cara Nakamura of course he deserves
all the credit that he gets and he's the
beast an absolute monster the Queen even
he's a growing celebrity on Twitch so it
won't be a surprise that we have a
majority of Nakamura fans but because we
also have a matchup left early play we
don't know who's gonna win yeah you're
right we also are curious based on
everything that we've heard and
different ideas and different feedback
to come across we figured this was the
best way to bring our really our entire
to a close right I mean this is a really
great question we'd love to get some fan
and community interaction to let us know
if you could change one thing about the
speech Chess Championship format what
would it be
right and when we talk format I think
we're looking for specific things that
you feel from your perspective would
either add more excitement or make it a
better format right I mean there's all
kinds of questions like players have to
have lollipops in their hand or
something like that but I think we're
talking specifically and we're looking
for some specific feedback that maybe
helps us continue to make what is one of
the most popular events and things to
watch online better for you to fan so
if you force me to guess I'm gonna
assume that a very popular answer will
be Fisher random chess official random
chess is something we had last year and
we took away so it's an interesting
question whether it should come back
regardless of whether Fisher random will
be played a lot of money will be paid
today to these two players they bucks
this is this is now you're now down to
the final matchup so there's a lot of
money on the line considering that it's
only a few hours of blitz here in
pajamas or in Hikaru's plate case plaid
shirts with a turtleneck which is also
great
yeah and look at well speaking what's
also great at car stats right his
probability went probably 67 percent
there's the two thirds favored here and
it's actually I think a little bit
closer than those stats may lead us to
believe yes a car of Nakamura Eaton -
that's exactly double foreign one record
for Wesley so there yeah and the 5-1
estimate I don't know that's good that's
where Hikaru got his edge and they're
really going well and that's where the
segment comes up right the 5-1 estimate
being slightly in favor of acara
Nakamura here right I don't you know I
think it'll be interesting I think
because we all know that a car Nakamura
is a beast in Bullitt we tend to always
have this overarching storyline if
you're gonna beat a car you got to have
a lead headed into bullet and I think
that's the kind of the same storyline
here we see that Wesley actually
slightly favored in the 3-1 segment
coming in so that's an interesting
little nugget to consider as we look at
the the breakdown of how these players
got here pretty fascinating stuff young
Chris stuff Duda again just I was really
impressed by Wesley snows dominance and
the bullet portion of that match look at
that well I see eight yeah almost
keeping pace with a car not chemours
dominance over Yvonne in fact I think
the +8 in an entire graphic here is the
most impressive thing to me out of
everything
yeah of course a Cara Nakamura that
gotten off to big scores but he started
off really well earlier at plus 25 in
the first round plus eight plus five but
look at was he so plus nine plus six
then plus 13 the semies and the pros aid
in the bullet that's where we know
Nakamura generally makes his money's
worth that worries me a bit for her car
Nakamura right well it just may mean
that we're not gonna have as lopsided of
a match as we might expecting right and
if you're if you're taking a lead in two
the fastest portion and feel like you
can hold your own that's got to be
giving you some confidence right so
we've we're looking ahead of course to
the final species championship match but
while we have everyone's attention we
will remind you that the next big thing
happening in the chess world starts on
January 8th when the pro chesley kicks
off the 2019 season will have 32 teams
launching their campaign I'm not even
sure who my favorite is it's it's gonna
be exciting I think I go by the logos of
the teams but as far as new faces or
faces that you're aware of coming back
we just saw Grandmaster Sam Franklin
Wesley so we'll be playing for the
archbishop's of course a car Nakamura as
we've been talking a lot about will will
be kind of back in his hometown as he
feels for Seattle playing for the
Seattle sluggers it's gonna be hard to
beat Wesley so and Fabiano Caruana
teaming up with the st. Louis
Archbishop's but if anyone can do it
he's gonna do it it might be the world
champion who defended his title
celebrated his 28th birthday and
probably enjoying a bit of a vacation
before he maybe helps lead the gnomes to
what he'd like to be lead like to see
maybe a 2019 Pro chesley championship if
you if you don't remember Magnus Carlsen
led the gnomes to the championship in
the first year the inaugural season they
did fall short ultimately but Magnus is
no stranger to helping his team go very
far in the fall short to in the first
year the archbishop that's right it was
it was st. Louis led by Wesley so yeah
at the time who I ended up taking home
the MVP price so in the 2017 season
Wesley so was the MVP and he ultimately
led the bishops to a victory the bishops
fell short in the semi finals last year
and guess who they didn't have playing
for them guess who's coming back this
year and the O's did not have
five-minute car wanna go guess he was
busy playing the candidates that's right
that's right chest pain 9 4 just
subscribed for 12 months in a row uh I
mean amazing it's so funny she spent so
much time gifting memberships to others
rarely see her name
subscribe yo so I just looked the chat
she says she has she messaged me
directed she has her bagel and her
coffee good she somebody's got to have
it we don't have a bagel for you right
now we do have a proble but I wouldn't
let you eat that if you tried yeah
that's pretty sad look after you
but alright well we're still a couple
minutes out I want to remind everybody
real quick of the format today we we
have the speeches championship this is
the finals we have had quite the year
with matches starting as far back as
August or even July if you include the
qualifiers and will let that sit on the
screen here so you can maybe read it as
you choose while I talk about it but
basically it's pretty simple we have a
massive knockout a bracket of 16 very
very strong chess players making it all
the way to where we are now in the
championship and the format runs from
blitz to bullet with all kinds of
excitement throughout the day and I
think we're gonna be in store for just
that today with the car Nakamura taking
on Wesley so I'm pretty excited and both
players have been with us for a while
they've been they were early hikaru
regularly streaming he's finding time to
play and win these events while also
streaming from his own channel twitch.tv
/gm Hikaru yeah you're focused on the
car I'm what's was the eating over there
I don't know he did offer you some
bagels before we started though I don't
think he's actually eating a bagel yeah
I don't know what he's eating but he's
aware apparently that you like bagels
Wesley now in st. Louis not in his
normal home environment there but we're
about to have liftoff here in just a
second the games will begin Oh
Hikaru is already rocking it rocking the
style the dogs have already been let out
we're still trying to figure out who let
them out but that's a whole other
discussion and and the games have begun
so we have we have a London / kind of a
tory / kali / robert what is this speak
quickly / it's a London because the
bishops not out right right but it but
if the structure almost started out that
way right with the ifs III have been
played you would actually of a collie
which is right kind of the the less
known sort of adopted brother of the of
the London and now it's kind of huge
Edie's Transpo's yeah with the Bishop on
b7 early we actually avatar took our qgd
but with a black not having castled yet
we're gonna have a weird little little
opening system here where we might
actually already be seeing
I guess Oh an opening mistake by Wesley
he's thinking Oh Gumby five right now
Queen d7 I thought 395 you take on b5
you lose cousin Knight takes b5 directly
uh other Queen has to move and we got
discover checks but you have this
in-between move Knight takes c3
attacking the Queen Center Knight 67
Knight takes a four and it's black who's
the one who's going up material yeah a
very very complicated tricky trade a
shout out to HP for three who's been
showing up to start every show with a
donation and it's like almost like
become the calling card of the speeches
championship so thank you so much for
all your support we've also already had
a number of subscribers and fans being
here so thank you so much and thanks to
all of our fans who got involved and
voted in the chest comm official poll
survey on the homepage we can see that
by that voting we have the okay yes we
have a very clear favorite yes we know
that but we also have the two most
popular vote getters here playing in the
final matchup so the story line can be
either Hakkar Nakamura's fan bases broad
no surprise on chest comm or the fans
got it right when they predicted the
vote the poll that started back on
Thursday that we would have Wesley so
versus Takara Nakamura yeah and you know
neither of us were particularly
surprised this happened we got more
surprising about how the result came to
me rather than the result itself and
right now speaking of results I think
the result the opening is favorable for
was they so with the black pieces I
generally speaking do not like this
pawnshop her c3 and d4 with white
because look at the c-4 square oh I love
that C 4 square that night is gonna come
from c6 to a5 my Brooke is go from A to
C 8 and I'm gonna keep your pawn
backwards on the C file and then put my
knight on c4 to plan it there so yep
ideally what happens for black is
actually we get a knight trade so right
v is now a threat for black in fact it
can be played maybe one good play yeah
yeah I was gonna say the knight can't
take it because the Queen discovery so
the reason why this works in fact Wesley
could have played it it's because the
Queen is undefended so this move doesn't
work unless you're into that and if the
Queen moves there's Knight takes f3 dude
did Wesley just miss that I'm not sure
but I mean I guess it's possible he was
that great what I'm into la genie
gifting 7 subs so that was already
generous wow thank you so much
and Kate well 95 is on the board now it
happened and if Queen takes d7 the
knight will have to take back and
retreat
that's where we're headed yep take no
you take a 3-wood check and in fact
Hikaru flashing the duck lips
five minutes in so somebody just lost
money in Vegas didn't take long for
those things to appear was it looks very
comfortable though yeah we have just
like now he's drinking something but we
did have his face just right in front
the camera what he's really just right
up against it or you know her car is not
looking so comfortable if he's got like
an HD zoom on well I've gotta show us
that his complexion is clear it's like a
you know I don't know it's a Proactiv
commercial you know proper proper acne
and skin care yeah looks great right now
he's now he's also looking great on the
board right I mean because here black is
headed to an endgame with a better pawn
structure the transition here even with
the past see pawn is it's gonna be one
where black is a little bit better head
into the endgame
yeah and black isn't actually throwing
to win the pawn and see if it looks like
it because you have more attackers and
defenders right but you back rank
problems yeah you have to throw in a
move like King f8 or or or start start a
plan of using what will eventually be
maybe your four on three minority sorry
majority you can also be a little more
aggressive with the pawn structure on
the Kings side if you want cars will sit
down a minute on the clock
yeah again we're really well on the
board and I'm on the clock so a rare
situation to see but you know you and I
talked about this after the match
yesterday knowing what we saw between
Wesley selling young Chris up Duda and
then seeing what happened between LaVon
and acara that while hey Karl won the
first two blitz portions and then
surprised us by actually losing the
bullet portion we did not expect your
car to to maybe easily win the blitz
portions today right just because I
think stylistically sometimes Wesley and
Hikaru are so contrasting that when
LaVon was all-in and those attacks and
Hikaru could just continue to out
calculate him brilliantly defend by the
way those games were just awesome
yesterday with Aronian I don't know that
we're gonna see those types of crazy
attacking games that Nicole really loves
here against Wesley in fact we already
see what's going to be a very technical
very kind of tricky end game where
Wesley's goal was to kind of grind out
victories and it
different a different way than what
lavon's looking to do in blitz yes yeah
in fact I think stylistically Hakkar
does not match up particularly well
against wasn't right we've seen that
play out in classical chess
yeah I mean various tournaments over the
years in the round one of the seen field
coupling 2016 was he defeated him in the
London chess classic a car but quite
poorly but also lost a Wesley and that
it scored a soup or solid set up by
Wesley just you know he's not always
looking for tactics he's just looking to
better his position move by move and
I'll play a card right now he's doing so
because that King is jetting from f8 to
d6 and then to d5 and there's no way for
white to stop them yep here it comes and
it's gonna be a Ning umber White has to
come up with the drawing setup now as
you can see his car taking his time
because he's thinking about doing so
remind you everybody of our daily
question we're getting our first
interaction on Twitter so thanks you
thank you to all of those of you who are
providing us with some constructive
feedback and and criticism and ideas
even just things you'd like to see
happen maybe from our older formats like
Fischer random and so keep getting
involved use the hash tag speech yes and
thanks for doing that
okay a quorum has set up this position
with the fish 25 but I'm still with you
in that okay first you deal with the G
pawn but once this Bishop finds an ideal
diagonal work and put pressure on d4 I
guess that's the question is how do you
do it how do you get that Bishop on a
diagonal where her car was pawn becomes
the first thing you have to consider is
Bishop f6 can't trade these bishops am I
going to the King important because the
bishop can't move as the d4 pawn say
okay was he decided that it's better
said not trade the bishops and he's
probably right yeah it's something you
always have to consider was nobody I
mean that's an interesting thing because
you have the more active King - right
right so this would have been an endgame
we're probably only black could win but
Wesley maybe thinks it's it's not going
to be a win so he'd rather keep the
flexibility of the bishops because the
advantages for Wesley here are numerous
in terms of pawn structure two pawns
that are likely to be permanently stuck
on dark squares the biggest issue Wesley
has is that if this bishop activates you
have to worry about things like Bishop
c7 Bishop h4 here I think just I just be
great so if Bishop h4 here comes Bishop
c7 and king c6 so you gain a tempo and
save and I can't get away with this I
think I can take you now I don't know I
have you it's really a move by move
calculation but trading it to the king
pawn game where my king as far more
advanced seems like at least a very
decent winning attempt right but that's
what the option was earlier and West
they didn't taken in again he doesn't
take it here I'm with you I agree I mean
clearly I think black would be playing
for two results there but what hit karo
has managed to set up here was kind of
instructive for everyone to see that yes
white is worse in this kingdom pawn
ending for numerous reasons Black has
the the better King Black has more
potential weaknesses on the dark squares
but a car was done the one thing that
could save it right he has a very active
Bishop that is gonna be constantly
threatening to hit this b6 pawn so um
just something I just thought about
another plan of action for Wesley's to
put H 4 which seems weird is black to
play h4 uh-huh but the point is I'm
gonna go g5 f5 and maybe g4 chime free
up a spawn
yeah on the outside that's an
interesting point that's the other issue
with a weakened pawn structure right
it's the potential of something like
that I think an issue when you think of
weak pollen do you think of being
targets but the other issue is when a
pawn leaves an area of the board behind
sometimes there's other other things you
can do to take advantage of it oh that's
interesting maybe he's preparing g5 next
move but whatever f4 Oh bad for kinky
for but then I need to cow kid again
because if you go F for kinky for the
enemy King c4 comes and yeah never race
I mean Wesley fortunately has the time
to calculator right it's a situation
where he is up on the clock against a
car oh okay Bishop h4 now hostage for
loose very voice Bishop g3 in Bishop f6
he forgot about this yeah this is tough
now for Hikaru this is tough for sure
and so you can go Bishop c7 but I'm
wondering if you either go King c6 back
or you can take on well king c6 was the
line we looked at because Bishop takes
f2 it would just be a trade otherwise no
but Bishop to Bishop d6 c5 oh very nice
key key point the bonus pin but maybe Y
just goes a 5 and says okay take that d4
pawn I don't really care about it take
with check and then all you have to come
to my a pawn
yeah but this would be a crazy race
right really really fun only you know I
think that actually liquidates into a
draw because the king will have to yeah
I'll have to run back and you'll win d4
agreed okay that's not what we're seeing
okay so look at this h4 comes the tempo
he's doing it he's going
with tempo and then played g5 okay I
guess it doesn't move or it doesn't have
to be super precise at this point but
the main points h4 is coming and then g4
breaking that past bond free
shoutout to liquid egg product with the
thousand bits we appreciate it buddy I
would say the one difference though is
Hikaru has achieved something with the
more active King position right
no the defenses oh and and maybe that
allows things like this maybe now he can
head into the King and pawn ending
because he's no longer having the weaker
King Bishop takes Bishop takes pawn
takes h4 is it Ritchie for first
actually I know h4 oh we're gonna find
out here comes here comes the threat of
g4 this might actually g4 he just missed
it before a new queen well you don't
have to take it twice you can stop the
Queen in a line like this but now that
King gets active exactly there it is and
a car missed it he completely missed you
see his face yeah he's in shock well as
we all know Hikaru is one of the most
entertaining follows on Twitch and
entertaining people we've ever had in
this format precisely because he lets
his emotions show yesterday we had a lot
of facial expressions a lot of fun with
the karo as he as he sort of cruised to
a victory against Levon Aronian in a
surprising way but if we're seeing
reactions like that today because Wesley
is setting a different tone
we may get some other hit car Nakamura
facial expressions that he doesn't want
to show yeah I think a great thing for
Wednesday is his mouth speed not just on
the bullet but the fact that he just
moves quickly he's a very fast player he
knows his positions quite well and so
being well-prepared and feeling
confident and as I think was it often
does yet allows him to move as quickly
as possible and yep I mean a surprising
oversight there by Hikaru and looks like
just so we have some tweets in here yep
we're getting some getting some
involvement with a daily question from
chess and black and white I love the
increment for blitz but one plus one
isn't real bullet one plus Oh is the way
to go interesting that would certainly
change things a lot in regards to how
the bullet portion is is viewed and
frankly I think it would make someone
who's made the finals three years in a
row Hikaru Nakamura potentially even a
favorite even if someone like Magnus
Carlsen competed next year I expect
we'll see tweets like one thing to
change about the sec is get Magnus back
obviously you know that he didn't play
this year because he was playing in a
a tournament in London and this year the
format didn't work for Magnus but of
course the invitation is always there
and we're hopeful and optimistic that
Magnus might be back next year I would
insert 12 classical games in before the
finals classic
I think that's sarcasm yes from john
reisel but we do appreciate the humor
anyway and likely not to happen so you
finished the humor I appreciate was this
nose position in this camp yeah he's
already better in a second game in a row
and this is going to be a different
match for those of you after seeing such
a dominant performance to a point where
we even saw the blonde cloud busted out
by Hikaru against Levon Aronian I'm here
to tell you I think today is going to be
a very exciting finals what the people
pay for Hikaru is the favorite for a
reason and he was favored statistically
but you can see it on Wesley's face you
can see he's already up on up on the
scoreboard and may be about to jump out
to a 200 lead Hikaru doesn't face 2 2
game deficits very often no not at all I
think so far I'm just by looking at his
face I'm breathing he's missing a lot of
things this b5 movement just happened
the car kind of made some eyes at the
move like whoa I really wasn't expecting
that and it's good because it keeps the
c-pawn stuck in its place you can't take
on b5 because then you drop c7 so right
now Wesley is really ramping up the
pressure on the queenside III will come
to see through at some moment to hit
that c7 pawn once more and yep I'm
really liking what was he's doing in
this match ok Knight f4 is an aggressive
attempt by Hikaru hoping to get to the
e2 square someday with an O and g3 is
what it also may be hoping to get an
attack on the Kings side this is kind of
typical in the structure of the issue
here for Black is the rook and Queen are
already sort of doing defensive tasks
and white is kind of ahead of that race
here comes the other look to c3 in a lot
of positions and I and I don't know that
Hikaru is gonna be able to muster up the
kind of attack you would want with a
couple nights and maybe even a rook
battery but again I just feel like this
is a little too slow given what white
already has yeah rook d1 actually can
force the Queen's off because yeah if
white plays rook do you want you to keep
your Queen tied to the rook on f7 and
you don't want to play Queen East sevens
and Knight f5 comes with the tempo and
Jesus Irish it's not fun and so Hikaru
is gonna have to offer the Queen trade
perhaps anyway already anticipating that
but I look at trades and an immediate
pressure packed battery on the C file
and you look at the e5 pawn you look at
this
seven bond right and actually after you
trade on e6 you have to take with the
rook to keep the e5 pawn defended in a
very direct sequence rookie to c3 as you
mentioned you have to go babe you know
night EA tour et e7 you're getting very
passive all of a sudden right and rook
c5 happens right hitting the e5 so as
you as you highlight it black has not
just one pawn weakness the obvious one
on c7 but this one over here as well I
like this move order rook c5 first and
now he can play rooks III just
yeah that's not very pretty for a car is
positioned this far team can some
questions for those of you just joining
us thank you for all 10,000 of you that
are already here let's remind everybody
of the prizes on the line just for
today's matchup so some of you asking
what's on the line just right now right
the this feat chess champion format has
more than 50,000 dollars in prizes but
just for today there's 10,000 in cash so
the winner takes home a clean five
thousand bucks for just three hours of
blitz not that bad and which not too
shabby shells for my favorite the format
because well you know it's not just five
minute segments as we are in now but
I've been three minute and then one
minute right so that'll happen
throughout the day but the prizes as you
can see $50,000 in total but 10,000 just
for this single match that you're
joining and watching right now again the
price has broken down is five thousand
to the winner and then the rest of the
prize money broken down by win
percentage so not a bad payday coming
today we've got we've got odd a lot of
people a lot of debate a lot of a lot of
discussion about what happened toward
the end of yesterday's match where
Hikaru busted out a bond code opening
first time ever maybe it opening like
that has been played against a super GM
like Aronian and then we have a bunch of
odds as to whether or not that happens
people saying 65% in 1+1 I'm gonna
challenge that and say I think it's much
smaller especially if this is a matchup
where Ricardo needs every every single
game as the clock ticks down because I
do believe we are in for a closer match
today it's not happening it's not you're
on the record it's not happening I'm on
the record because I think wuzzy is
gonna go toe-to-toe with him yes the
first game was a great performance by
Wesley you know he got that passed pawn
he won the endgame here with the white
pieces he's just better and it car was
feeling the pressure and like I said
stylistically I think Hikaru struggles a
bit with Wesley and I think was his
mouse speed makes up for any sort of
predation I did see we did see the
Vaughan lose several time scrambles
right like he just didn't quite have it
to compete with
carl in the push come to shove where it
sits how fast is your mouse right and
wesley plays a lot more on chess calm
right he's a regular commodity both just
playing casually you can just click on
his username right there and bring up
his profile
protip you can also type in any chat on
chess comm / archive username and you'll
get all that person's games so if you're
on chest coms live chest server right
now
type / archive and either username and
see what they do so
yeah wesley is a lot more active right
online then then Levon is and might be
might be headed for a peaceful result
here though and indeed we are
I think acardo's got to be happy with
that he kind of questions it with the
eye roll there that might have been a
suggestive hit over number 13 which is a
suspicious look yeah and here goes the
car go back to what he knows
here goes the car back to what he does
best with the facial some of the facial
expressions we caught on tampered
yesterday two of our favorites of the
duck lipstick are on the left and
wha-hey karo on the right so now he's
been look at the chess board here cuz
he's back to his old tricks of playing
openings that he specializes in frankly
in terms of online blitz and bullet and
this night of three be free system is
I'm betting something we're gonna see
numerous times today yeah thank you my
beloved for the South and also thanks to
the chess browser ad in the channel but
that I mean this face is just priceless
yeah but a car needs to get something
going here I think he's worse again with
the white pieces it's pretty level in
the sense that there four minor pieces
six pawns of two works aside yeah but if
you just look at the setup here the
bishop on c4 is actually a very vital
piece and it's especially vital because
look at this King on e 2 if this bishop
were removed from the c-4 square and
let's say I could get some kind of quick
attack on it or as was he might just go
for Knight b6 this Bishop quickly runs
out of squares and if I can get that
Bishop off the board their squares to
infiltrate from like d3 and as I was
trying to say before if after exchanging
get my Bishop on this diagonal that
would be very nice for black so I think
in the early stages here I slightly
prefer blacks position should be ok for
for what but he needs to be careful a
car really needs to make sure that he
doesn't lose the threat of this game as
in the first two games it's been all
Wesley so and a car still he's kind of
going closer to his computer here yes
what is Wesley doing over there he's
maybe a little bit nervous he's bouncing
around in his chair trying to get comfy
he's got a plug in the batteries all the
computers gonna die classic these are
real-world problems when you're playing
in an online Chess Championship right
there so crisis averted apparently the
laptop now has power and Wesley back to
focusing pretty funny yeah that's pretty
good but ok a 6 exactly yeah c5 scores
well defend if you move the knight away
from b6 then c5 feels vulnerable now b5
is a huge threat
yep I ate four is a movie definitely
don't want to play but you may have to
it pins the a pawn so just to show the
obvious tactic b5 runs into a penny mode
but the reason Robert doesn't want this
is because the b3 pump becomes such a
future target such an awkward backward
pawn to deal with in fact very directly
Knight b6 to anything might be six yeah
trying to unload the bishop which would
loosen the defense of the b3 pawn or
squared look at that an aggressive move
by Hikaru
I like that a much more forcefully this
is Hikaru Nakamura's way of of dealing
with most issues right brute force and
head-on with aggressive chess so he
plays v4 he's gonna put the pressure on
his opponent to out calculate him in
most games and so I guess the question
is where do you put this knight he's
only two squares efore and a four a four
is a sort of strange square because it's
not centralized but the same time you're
going to play b5 pretty soon and it's
gonna be offended on that outpost square
yep
either square it's likely gonna be met
by b5 because even if the Knights on e4
you might want to play the pawn to b5
and get the bishop to b7 so Wesley
having to make a big decision early on
in this game here because I think as you
said this is a knight on the edge but
okay if it's protected it actually pokes
maybe at some critical opportunities and
Wesley agrees and goes for that idea and
the b4 pawn is hanging as well so it's
not so clear-cut so free zone b5 it
looks like you might get into trouble if
your bishop takes a foreign if I was
just played because Bishop a4 pawn takes
me that a pawn is a little weak but the
B four pawns also immediately under
target
and then the light square bishop will
dominate or black in a position like
this
so right hikaru wisely and calmly plays
a3 and so my immediate reactions do I
play a5 like am I in time to do that or
is that a little bit of too much and you
should develop first of the bishop of b7
okay he's a knight back to b6 which I
don't particularly love because now
white can develop and they c3 without
any major consequence yeah I think the
Carter has actually seen the worst of
this opening and that's not a surprise
in the sense that the early going when
you play Knight of three and B three
maybe it's not the most aggressive
opening but he caught replaced these
positions so often he knows it like the
back of his hand and Wesley maybe has a
good start as black but as the game
develops on I think Hikaru knows these
middle game tactics Robert like better
than any other grandmasters that play DS
yeah and I think that's why you you
often see him it's not a swindle but
kind of you know slowly kind of you know
get jiggy with it over time work his way
into a better person I'm not exactly
sure what this is here that I was doing
yeah didn't know I dad bought shuffle
pretty much Patton did buy this guy but
no I think that that's what Hikaru does
best in this system right and it's not
not gonna be a battle like we saw
necessarily Wesley versus young
Christophe though we did seem since
Pilate sideline openings actually we saw
more theory yesterday with Nakamura
versus Aronian yes I mean it was it was
Italian their head butting right um I
don't think we're gonna see the same
type of games today I think we're gonna
see some different unique systems
employed mainly by Hikaru yeah I think
was he would be happy to go into his
theory and his repertoire and for hey
Cara playing ideas b3 and rhymes like
that a little more offbeat allows him to
play quicker chest yep and look at the
clock situation right now as you said it
card knows these positions pretty much
better than anybody that's why you don't
right now 40 seconds and again he takes
his time I think that's an accurate move
he doesn't just want to develop this
night because because he has to write he
hard carros trying to get the long-term
winning chances by opening up the a file
and maybe having a weakness over here to
deal with so now it now we'll probably
see 92 or 93 and maybe because you want
this night to get to e4 and hit f6 but I
guess if the knight develops black will
simply put a bishop to I'd that square
say karo calculating something like this
bishop
I don't think worst is night d3 hitting
both works at the same time the a1 rook
and the c1 so I think that would be yep
too much to give to Wesley and so now
was he's fully developed I think the
worst is also behind him just a couple
moves ago I was worried about his setup
and maybe I should still be with some
knight b3 to c5 ideas but I think it's
getting better for him his chances of
holding this are definitely improving
yep shadow to Maynard monkey we know how
much he loves subscribing to channels if
there wasn't oh I know I know it's a bit
of an inside joke oh shut out shout at
me just thank you so much for the love
Manor monkey I don't know enough about
Manon really appreciate it well alright
so we're back to this one here Bishop to
b7 and okay maybe f3 guard she too and
and then go back to ideas were you ready
use this night I mean you could also say
now na that you would say Donna no no no
no no no no yeah I had apparently
getting jiggy with it on the mind but no
I don't think you would give up the Jeep
on I was quickly calculating could I
actually do that and try to use that for
some counter play but I don't think so
yeah cuz the black and I can always drop
back to g6 and just close down the file
yeah but now hit carro taking his time
here so unlike what we saw earlier he's
now down on the clock just says what we
did see in Game one surprise he took
some longer play that move f3 but maybe
he was calculating ideas where he could
be more aggressive yeah very strange I
mean that's oh he said a lot of time
there he's down now by 30 second those
really praising him because he was up so
much time not a bit more you know but ok
White's plan isn't too difficult maybe
three is still a very good looking move
throw the 1985 or c5 like it's a space
crap and you're trying to claim that the
pawn a six is weaker than the pawn on
before because the there are no targets
on the kingside right all four pawns for
both sides are hard to get to
yep so it's really what's gonna happen
on the Queen side and so Knight b3
coming next I think was he what h3 that
I don't maybe he's trying to go f4 and
then the King side but I really just
thought a knight b3 made sense
so if I'm whizzy maybe I played Bishop
d5 whoa okay g5 yeah
so you're kind of slowing down the pawn
structure but I think you really just
want to free your back rank and threaten
the move King g7 but a karo immediately
gonna try to punish what g5 just did
which is leave this Bishop undefended on
f6 the main point is a simple trade it's
just clearly much better for white right
now has the bishop pair and targets to
go with it whoa God he's going for it
but this is gonna be great for Hikaru
yeah it definitely is a big advantage
for white now and Hikaru yes so so g5
definitely a regrettable decision by
Wesley and it may be one that ultimately
levels the match here because Hikaru is
is playing for two results here but the
one thing I do like what was he what was
he says after he made this bad move I
got served with g5 he played to follow
up quickly and he needs to keep going
yup can't start getting down to 20
seconds look 97 played quite quickly
doing everything fast he's doing
everything fast and again he that's the
right you know he's got his head I think
in the right place right he brought his
he's kind of pregame knowledge I can't
afford to get down against a carro on a
consistent basis um but I still don't
think this is an easy draw especially
when you look at the fact that White has
the dark squares the bishop pair with
pawns on both sides of the board this is
a hakuro specialty here comes moves like
H for prying open the dark squares on
the end he does it I agree Hikaru is is
gonna be pressing here as both sides get
under time pressure yep but I still like
I completely agree with you white is
better wise can press on both sides of
board but I liked it was it continues to
play quickly yes in a bullet game in a
worse position and oftentimes during
that situation you set the place quickly
as possible yeah but you playing well
still and look this is a five
dangerously what Bishop becomes I was
gonna say and f7 has now been opened as
a target Bishop c4 is gonna stop very
very nice move yeah Bishop c4 Bishop a4
I'm thinking here karo will play he oh
he takes it I thought you played Bishop
a4 cuz undermining the knight would hit
e5 oh but he has a tactic when you take
it I think you can take it you have
Knight c5 check afterwards rook takes
before Bishop me 395 check oh my gosh
there it is in fact he seized it maybe
he Karim is calculating c4 you can't get
to my Knight rook c4 and rugby 5 either
yeah yeah actually a trick from Hikaru
is not gonna pay off and probably we are
gonna see a peaceful result which is a
very very nice hold by Wesley right
right okay
Nick are not giving up on trying to win
yet though and again I think that's the
right practical approach Accardo can't
ever ever kind of say all right you've
defended in the X's and O's say this is
a draw to try hey Carl needs to get
these games under mutual time pressure
and show why he's the online blitz and
bullet King now he's up you know and now
he's on that's that this is this is how
a car was gonna win a lot of games in
this match regardless of the X's and O's
he's gonna create this mutual time
scramble but Wesley's quick I really
like the fact okay Brooke before I don't
like that move okay for right away they
should be four I mean this is like
Wesley's gonna have to keep playing
great moves under time pressure put
himself in a pass okay there we go
finally rook on a better square rights
to keep both pawns protected white can't
actually easily make progress here as
you know the one really good thing as
the night is so dominating this Bishop
on it I think what white just missed
rook e8 check winning on the spot and of
course shaking his head look at that
move after King e6 acara was winning in
one move with rook e8 and rookie seven
and he missed it
yeah she was blunder by her car when he
shook his head but it may not matter I
think he's gonna go on to win this game
no matter what yeah what it was he's
trying to sacrifice his night for those
two pawns so I don't think he's to get
the opportunity now yeah the bishop will
go to d6 and arrive here comes a mating
net yep check okay check you have to go
six also now the threat is rook e8 check
Alina lush Lamba wait for a while here
we have six king of six and he's fine
waiting for almost blunders he shakes
his head and Wesley just resigns cuz
despite the blunder he he's still losing
but again and I wasn't trying to like
paint the you know say the writing is on
the wall but I do believe that as we
were analyzing that we were we were in
X's and O's mode and you kept talking
yes he's holding and I'm just like
looking at the fact that this is exactly
what a car wants yeah the mutual time
pressure that was created there I'm no
longer totally evaluating whether Wesley
played the correct defense because under
time pressure you're gonna have to
continue to find moves hikaru is not
gonna take on c5 after after Wesley
found this rook before and I see five
right he's
keep creating opportunities for you to
blunder under time project objectively
this shipment holdable but yeah right
you know time trouble is the worst
nightmare for anyone playing a Cara
Nakamura yeah he had the bishop and the
bishop is just controlling the night in
the end game so right now
was he going back to the Italian game
the card needs to find something because
I didn't like his position yeah he was
already defending very early on so he
played a lot of Italian against Lev
though so maybe he feels like that's
where he needs to live given that it was
successful yesterday but so taking a
different approach
I mean Lev was all in with the Bishop g5
variations right and all the attacking
chances on the Kings side the sacrifices
Wesley has a much more positional
approach here yeah he doesn't want to
get into those tactics and I think it's
a good strategy again secure we saw how
great he is it Tigers yesterday and
we've seen it many many times taking
just the slower approach gonna gain
space I can play up d5 treat my bishop
with a bend play on the Kings side right
once you deal with things on the in the
center and on the Queen side you can
then go a free play over yeah and yeah
as you said it's just taking your slow
jamming this one to have the free play
long-term versus the more much more
aggressive much more direct lines that
levels playing for but at karo okay
playing uh playing quickly as well here
so he knows his Italian just like Wesley
does time about even whoa okay just emu
c5 yeah I mean this gives you like it
makes you kind of squeal and throw up a
little bit back your throat but
sometimes in blitz and bullet you can
get away with positional disasters of a
move the reason we hate that is because
d6 becomes weak the light squares become
weak it's like what you can't play that
way in chess but you know black is
trying to create a lot of open dynamic
tactics here I think yeah trying to open
up the position and say you know it's
not fun to sit passively yeah alright
when you have concrete plans and we saw
a 500 car wanna talk about in the World
Chess Championship it's magnified in
blitz chess when you do it up do not
have the time to come up with anything
so you just like let's just trade a few
pieces we always say the side with the
less space yet wants fewer pieces on the
board still not restricting each other
look at this rookie three were left
heading right to g3 right and and
potentially positions right so you've
got both the g7 pawn and the d6
that you can spy with this rook on the
elevator and you might play f4 585 yeah
with full force behind no and I agree
with you even though we kind of said
that's what a car wants dynamic go and
play I I think our instincts as decent
chess players that we are not as strong
as these guys but I think our instincts
are still correct that c5 is a very
positionally dubious move by a car I
mean if you look at this position it's
like yuck and white is definitely a
little better objectively but but will
the open kind of dynamic that hit car
was created here he's got pressure he's
got a B to fajn he's also got some dance
moves he's bobbing his head over there
I'd consider rook f3 here an exchange
sacrifice oh you know are you trying to
take on a six and put my knight on d5
yep so she looks like a very good move
rook of three looks good I also think
that rook D free and just kind of
preparing the discovery against the the
d6 pawn is just gonna be a headache I
also like rook g3 sorry I like a lot of
rook moves and apparently he doesn't
like any of them I think he was probably
weird of rook C forest at some point
okay rook g3 was very direct threat but
versus he was coming anyway right he's
sitting calmly saying that once my
Knight moves I won't do it yet cuz he
for falls but once my Knight moves d6 is
a big problem yeah and I play f3 move
Knight I think the ideal said it over
protect this pawn just so that you don't
don't worry about blacks pressure
anymore right and the idea has to put
that knight on d4 and either II threw
her f4 and just thrown on the d5 square
right that's the really nice thing the
pawn d6 is weak and it's backward and it
cannot be pushed yep and maybe he's
gonna push it now because well I think
tactically that would be what a car was
looking for and he okay he doesn't after
that little thing but Queen c5 might be
preparing just that so and Roberts
instincts are likely correct because
obviously these guys know that once they
have a weakness like this it's not their
favorite thing to just sit with it but
Queen c5 prepares to other things Robert
prefers b5 and the Queen sliding over
here to the Kings side in some positions
yeah to meet b5 that's what a3 is
placing upon I see 2 to b4 right there
this becomes an outpost a very weird one
but there's no nothing to attack it so
Bishop c6 hitting d5 I think we'll see
f3 now but the prize as soon as f3
happens you lose the rook to g3 so maybe
you're right maybe we'll get the all in
attacking approach rather than the the
the calm
no okay Wesley likes the positional
approach doesn't want to make it too
messy here when you have a better
position with more space and no clear
make sense does make sense
yeah that's their egos naked I see 293
is a big threat both ninety-three and
your idea that you highlighted before
this is actually a very nice square
because even though it looks weird as
you said it heads for a bigger picture
goal on d5 at some point right where you
have a very dominant night in the center
the Brooks is trapped in c4 - yep yeah
oh you're right this is a concrete fret
like hey you don't over here did you
come too far buddy time to go home mom's
calling dinner's ready
get off a c4 yeah Queen e5 check could
e5 check creates that opportunity to to
get that rook home for dinner
provoking f4 to weaken the e4 square but
I think was it will just retreat his
king yeah again here oh no so we've been
waiting for that and maybe now he sees
it as well right d6 is hanging a 5 and
e5 might win a piece okay we got a
calculate but I think that we've been
seeing Wesley take this sort of very
position I'd rather massage my advantage
home approach I think that's the right
practical one against a car ooh but when
you're given a concrete opportunity to
win material nobody wants to walk away
from them yeah that car looks very
displeased right now yeah Oh actually 93
steel traps that rook and mini lines as
well so it's okay this efore pawn is
hanging so you can't do it right just
yet what happens after Queen h5 been a
g5 threatens Knight g4 in some positions
on his pinned I guess you can just take
on d6 that yeah it's just a pawn and
like what's up right so Hikaru goes to
c5 but Wesley takes it anyway and
probably five follows
looks like a very clean straightforward
play here for white now yes Wesley
feeling very good about what he's gotten
out of the Italian early in this match
so Brooke takes d5 Bishop to c5 Knight
you know it doesn't quite work I was
like sort of concrete calculation you
because you don't go to Knight takes d5
because rook takes c2 right with a
little Intermezzo but there may be some
tactic here I mean like Queen no they
should take it yeah okay
ship take so Hikaru kind of bobbing his
head maybe he feels like he did swindle
his way out of losing that d6 pawn but
okay there's other moves here for
white connect in 93 they just force the
trade yeah it's the point of 93 is if
you try to take care I take care in
between move so I wonder if Wesley's
calculating whether 93 is a clean way to
get out of it but is this an idea and
this has just become quite de what a
mess what a mess you don't normally see
the rooks sort of you know normally the
rook is back here right the rook is
accelerated ahead of the minor pieces
and an f-14 you get an awful lot to
calculate here was he sells enough time
and especially good I think his position
is still good objectively yeah whoa whoa
rookie for okay Caro Caro zoned in now
those are the death stare eyes he
respects that move though that's the not
a respect that's like okay maybe I
missed this and quick calculation tells
me you did good you did good kid and now
I got to calculate we've gone oh man I
don't even know where to go with it but
you should go to twitch.tv a /g in the
car and give him a follow cuz he is a
rising star really the first super
Grandmaster to be actively engaged with
you the twitch community and Brooke
takes c3 sacrifice the that may also
have been desperate I know it's a
shocking one because we didn't see it
coming but he's still probably worse
here if Wesley finds the right moves
yeah but what are those right moves
great question take seats no if you
don't if you give back the exchange
right away it's probably not ideal but
if you move the rook here comes 94 right
yeah he does it it has to take on e4 I
guess but at a 24 and then night before
anyway white is still better right
take on e4 and then the knight comes in
to either be 4 or d4 but that Bishop is
really irritating classic hikaru and
look at who's up on the clock I was
gonna say he also can do this and play
like Queenie ok Queen d4 same idea
hitting the night yeah trying to claim
that because of pawns an a4 it's
actually a weakness yeah rather than a
strength in an endgame yep and that
might be the simplification Wesley
needed to just make sure he didn't
blunder under time pressure but I will
say right now hey Cara seems to have
kind of worked his way out of that
complex middle game I don't think he's
clearly worse anymore yeah he's gonna
protect his pawn he can also often trade
into a safe trade
said pawns go get four on three I need
to draw that way to be able to draw
that's not fun to do in a blitz game in
fact they just agreed to a draw so
quality chess there from both players
Wesley saying I'm not even gonna try to
push this endgame on yep
time for those draw emotes to be shown
by all 14,000 of you with us whether
you're at chess comm TV I think you also
have draw emotes at chess TV or twitch
TV slash chess thanks for being here and
this is the speech Chess Championship
finals this is it this is the last this
is the last major match of the year
right we had a match in London you and
I've been covering for a month yep we've
had a couple matches these last few days
and the semi-finals but this is I mean
if I'm a match there are there's one
other really big tournament maybe two to
bring the calendar year to a close with
the London chess classic and if he ever
gets their act together maybe a world
rabbit and bliss who knows but but this
is the biggest event really remaining on
the calendar so thanks for being with us
that's the format those are the prizes
at stake and we appreciate everybody
who's here yep and what I don't
appreciate those King on e to again and
I know it's sort of in the spirit of the
position right no queens are on the
board also not the boys out so certainly
no got to give him that the delayed bond
cloud the delayed bond cloud yep but
getting taken and with your King Ani to
do all the light squares around it feel
very vulnerable not that it was the
lights would be any better if the King
were 92 yeah I know but you're right but
okay I'll play devil's advocate to that
the point is as you said the light
squares are gonna be weak no matter what
when this Bishop has traded Robert so
maybe he's the king is trying to help
that cause of defending by already
proactively guarding to d3 square we see
Wesley kind of eyeing that right
potential Square for a night so maybe I
agree it feels very flimsy for white and
if this bishop comes off for either of
these nights you just start looking at
light squares you start seeing diagonals
and
you got nightmares and and so this
should be bad nightmares and Bishop
mares and Freddy Krueger's there but
he's like a nice Freddy Krueger with a
version of the stream like it's just
real weird yeah you know I don't know if
Freddy Krueger ever was nice but well
that's why I said it was a weird version
of the dream right we got nightmares and
Bishop mares and a happy Freddy Krueger
Oh
nice change of pace here our producer
trying to get us back on track the daily
question nice way to spend a cold
blustery Sunday so this isn't even
necessary an answer to our daily
question which is what would you do to
improve the format but we've got someone
showing us how they're tuning in and
watching very well-balanced Christmas
tree if I might say I take my Christmas
tree decorating very seriously very
nicely lit I'm gonna guess that's a fake
tree because the lights are so balanced
and because a lot of the fake trees
these days come with the lights
pre-wired so but anyway good work there
from LJ Nielsen and good work by Wesley
so to be up on the clock and I'm a
better position oh maybe not so much so
better I'm being a little too quickly
but I just really am NOT a fan of car
setups as far with the white piece yep
and especially now you give up your
darks for Bishop that bishops coming a3
in order to be for disrupting White's
setup okay so a3 now threatens before
that's not even work the biggest threat
because then I can take on see ya after
and again did this bishop I feel like
his his fate has been sealed but the
longer Wesley doesn't gain now he take
those because they the longer you don't
take it White was actually threatening
to retreat that Bishop to safety finally
because the knight had guarded b3 so
okay now black has the bishop pair and a
small edge but is it gonna be enough I
like Bishop b5 so that I might threaten
have six coming and so does Wesley a4
that's why white one a four because
black could actually play for an under -
I was gonna say I can keep the bishop
though because there's no real threats
on the c6 where the Carver backs up IX
no way yes you can keep the bishop
because note that b6 is not hanging due
to the pin on d3 so any moment b5 is a
breast for black perhaps perhaps now is
the time to do it it feels like YY help
clarify it for white though if you open
the a file it to me it feels like you're
getting closer to equality
okay well Wesley agrees with you and
ayissha said yeah I don't know that I
agree because if takes takes I feel like
if if y can clarify things and
ultimately trade the a for the b-pawn
now everybody's back to one side of the
board and and I feel like Wesley's edge
might be slipping I actually have a
different view on that
okay because I think that without
pushing forward on the queenside you
wouldn't actually you don't have enough
okay that's another pawn on b3 is a
target then you can try to and and and
you make a good point why can't just
take here because we're constantly
dealing with this knight on d3 or even
the King behind it right right just as
much of a problem and so a four is
always gonna be a possibility perhaps it
might be too soon but a four feels like
a move just because the Knights are not
very good against the bishops here after
politics a for Bishop takes a for a
bishop can always retreat to be v square
and or pinning these nights and nights
are tricky when defending each other
because and I can't go to e5 to go f6 to
kick a night out it was the b2 you're in
a very passive position I only like was
right now okay but I guess again I'm
playing devil's advocate based on the
fact that I liked it before and felt
like maybe I had long-term chances
against the weak pawns and if I don't
get tactics with the bishop pair
structurally I now have nothing we're
just four on four on the kingside and a
bunch of bunch of happy neighbors right
how you what do you do with your Knights
that's the center no can I can i DIF and
I trade rooks and then move it yeah but
always be nice like an outpost or they
need somewhere where they feel safe I
guess I'm looking at ideas where I trade
and move and and where's the basics okay
now I'm headed here okay I'm just keep
you pinned at every moment rights I
agree but I feel like how do you win I
just go fisherman eight six hey I'm just
gonna keep pressuring you until you kind
of collapse Bishop before you want to
beat me with tactics you dirty dirty man
that might not work okay I hear you I
mean I'm not neither we're not really
disagreeing I think the arguments fun
for everybody it helps them feel like
there are issues and tension in our
mirror now that was a very happy me
right now it's just awful because two
rooks are on the board you're losing the
c4 Knight and I noticed how you ignored
my relationship question okay well you
ended up being right hey karo didn't
figure out the tactics enough and in
fact now it looks like he's just losing
a PC five and five comes forcing a three
he's trying to get that's the Hikaru I'm
trying to figure out where I went wrong
that's actually hit car number 14 which
is not a good hit car because it means
he's living
the past so that was a that was an eye
that's the eye roll back to number 11
that's okay he's calculating but he's a
little bit of a cough he seems to be a
little cold he was warming very wearing
very wear warm clothes yesterday if I
can speak but so maybe he's a little
cold he keeps blowing on his hand trying
to maybe warm his fingers up his pieces
Campbell just King g7 here hey White has
a shuffle backless fourth yeah he was
gonna come to e7 I guess any moment you
can even take on d3 well and I anyway at
the right moment to go into a winning
King opponent get it the time that
correctly
yep but I thought he's Neil King g7 King
age 16 age five and run that way alright
now used to be a little bit careful as
night be to at least allows trades into
the King upon ending it is it enough I
believe it is he's gonna get the pasty
pawn and it probably is yeah the past
pawn is usually good enough to win
especially when you're up a pawn in a
king upon anything so ii v is coming
which will either happen with E for and
then the white king is simply stuck to
those swears and if we're just providing
instruction for all those wondering why
we saw resigns up too late next game no
it doesn't for you no instruction for
you I just totally folds you you thought
you were gonna learn something no shout
out to everybody that's with us we have
45 minutes roughly here left in the
first portion and we have a lead for the
man who was the underdog according to I
think both the human and statistical
predictions right if you were here early
you saw our pregame talk the stats had a
carro at about a 66 to 33 34 % favorite
something like that maybe 67 to 33 and I
think that's how most humans would see
it yeah right it seemed like more fair I
mean the smarter chess stats take a lot
of heat but I think in this case most
people tend to agree with them but when
you look at the roads that these two
took to get there you see Wesley getting
better with every match right Robert he
beat Wei Yi then he beat Duda I'm sorry
then he beated then he really beat Duda
and so Wesley Wesley ready for this and
right now he's got the lead yeah and
actually what I really
appreciate from the perspective of if
wasn't gonna win this match is that he
won the first game yep he went ahead
then hick are tied it up and now he's
took the lead again right some people
when they lose their lead they really
start tilting and collapsing well he
says not like that the only time he
tells us when he's goes to eat a bagel
or as head right tilt or sipping if you
tilting back yeah sipping something he
we did see him drinking horseshoes
earlier yeah I know I I agree and I
think he's not gonna be somebody who
beats himself and so he car was gonna
have to have to take this one right it's
not gonna be handed to him and I already
like once again I think this Italian has
not worked out for her carro in the
early going and we saw him do it so
successfully with black against Levon
but remember for those of you who are
the the real hardcore SCC fans you know
that the Italians we were seeing
yesterday were different in the approach
that Levon was playing aggressively for
the early development the dark square
bishop which led to all those both we
had sacrifices and a lot of crazy
positions on the kingside Wesley if you
just look at the live position a much
more positional and much slower approach
he's consistently had batteries on the C
file Robert right he's got an open file
here and and here again we have two like
white slight advantage yeah and if you
look at the position black is missing an
F pawn and Y is missing a C pawn but
blacks Queens I can't move so easily
whereas if white gets that King side
going it's a big problem right black
King you'd love to just do something
like this oh yeah those chess comm bugs
and then that nh7 looks terrible because
there's no future yep and so with the
Queen coming to d3 you're going to start
focusing on the King side and you always
watch out maybe there'll be some tax
with Bishop takes h6 at the right moment
if the black Queen Queen g6 comes Chuck
coming yeah just you have to be very
very careful for her car not just be
losing on the spot let's see maybe 9 h2
to g4 is another idea so many ideas
positive Knight h4 to g6 there's a gain
more space you're just doing that
because you know y'all love highlighting
Knight moves yeah it's a Christmas game
here comes f4 f5 by the way hi 405 is
coming 96 to start and then here comes
the F pawn yeah you probably trade the
night because the Knights a better
defender here or if you get rid of the
Starks for a bishop in the future to
know
have you no weaknesses that the bishop
can target bishop just because if I take
the knight I feel like the rook will
take back and maybe you can control the
FI a little better yeah you know I was
thinking more of an attack right I was
thinking if I if I get rid of this guy
and I do manage f4 f5 the knight is such
a useful defender on the King but okay
Wesley agrees with you he gets rid of
the bishop and and the truth is f4 f5 is
coming fast anyway and and now the dark
square bishop really doesn't have a
challenger right and that's important so
if your f4 g6 you probably still go f5
yes back upon for the h-bond brute force
well what is queen g6 I can't be a 5 is
coming anyway isn't it it feels so
inviting
Wesley kind of was that you had the
Leanback position but he laid into the
rock away no he didn't do the Rockaway
instead he sat up and pulled up his
pants maybe Big Pun would say right yeah
right queen of three well why did
sometimes the slope Roach is not the
right approach and like how was he been
playing yeah some critical moments we
have to punch through yeah he's finger
it seemed like f5 was ready yeah it was
ready and he didn't take it and maybe
it's coming anyway and I'm seeing my
words but somehow night b5 or knight c6
hitting the d4 square like nice 267
right ok I actually don't like 95 well I
think he's gonna hit both these pawns
now and III was thinking we might see it
because the counter-argument there is
who's better the knight of the bishop at
least I've gotten this Bishop off of
this dangerous diagonal right to be 7
very quickly to stop f5 or that FS is
such a valuable move for white to play
then yeah and you may be right I mean
obviously Wesley got it and if it works
out does he take d5 or f5 that's the
question that's what he's calculating
there's d5 so wow we have uh I called
someone out dude
the tree is fake but I spent like an
hour putting those lights on haha it's
not decorated yet though I had to stop
to watch the chest ok great
so I was half right the tree is fake but
the lights were done manually so Touche
LJ Nielsen you win this round
alright now uh Wesley takes a sip of the
OJ he did manage to take the d5 font as
you said Robert and now now actually
this Eddie Eddie the Eagle
like in his future as a lady named Ellen
over there where you mentioned smarter
chest before ya just mess with me
Leslie's won all five of the three plus
one time segments before including his
win over Magnus as you mentioned so yeah
this is why a car needs to do well the
five-minute segment what because he
didn't beat Magnus he lost him AG knows
he's beat max in that segment okay yes
when you said including his win over
Magnus I was specifically with a
three-minute portion so yeah I'm just
sipping the juice what was it no use but
did he just make a horrible trade by
giving up g3 for the other night what
just happened here well he he took d5
and I was I was touting him cuz I love
the potential of like I said Eddie Eddie
going for a 8 but Queen back to a 2 gave
up the night and this trade looks like
it may haunt Wesley because Hikaru kind
of turned the tables here although that
Bishop on b2 does look like a great
piece but I agree with you that Hikaru
has seen the worst passing by but he may
seem a second storm cometh an attacking
grew up with that bish 1 b2 that's a
great diagonal flat piece rook takes d7
is surely what the car was calculating I
didn't think it panned out because the
Queen would infiltrate 86 yeah I like
its Queen on g3 that's yeah and I like
here Carlos disciplines you said not
taking right away to allow 26 he's gonna
try to take this pawn slowly now he's
probably gonna take his time to defend a
5 here no reason to trade off d7 for a 5
yep Knight back to d6 and heads into e4
that's it that's a square that nobody
wants a knight on if you're playing
white yeah that's looking if you can't
do it right away because rook takes f5
so maybe you just take on d7 here first
then a4 is really threatening yeah so
okay takes with this rook because as
Robert said now this night for Paris
moves like rook d2 boy is it rook takes
f5 rookie to I can take you for an eye
guard g2o that's problem so he he
probably queen III check first so that
actually there was tactically that was
good for black mm-hm but Leslie both of
them missed it that's what Queen b3
display which yeah let's just show that
for the for the fans I check on e3 check
on e3 first
and then bend your idea okay cool so
yeah so potentially hikaru missing
missing a more forceful way to break
through but still massaging an edge here
because if white takes on b3 this pawn
oops that's that's no good they're
[Laughter]
making up jokes I don't know what
happened with that I was making a queen
roof while Hikaru was wrestling me or
Wesley was listening for the Queen to go
here and there you go a takes b3 and
this night would have come to c4 so that
didn't happen instead we had Queen takes
c6 and 94 so works and 94 Brooke takes
f5 here there so Queenie to be checked
so you have to be very careful for
Wesley because your king is not very
safe and the point is that the Queen III
check I protect my knight and here I
think this is exactly what's coming on
the board and after king h2 you can
overlook d2 exactly and the big threat
is not just the bishop on b2 but Queen
g3 check takes on g2 so this is gonna be
a win for a car with the black pieces
was he had a extremely good position I
would be a little bit frustrated if I
were him and I also know what it's like
to have good positions against super
grandmasters and then just lose them in
pretty heartbreaking fashion so this one
is going to be all Hikaru and I think we
just resign here Hale played Bishop e5
and hope that it works out but yeah hope
for hope for rook takes you two not to
work that's what I want yeah of course
you want to sacrifice it why not it
works I think it does work yeah a little
bit of puzzle rush in me right now I
admit I'm a bit of an addict
but hey that looks like something that
should lead to victory
there's a problem the g7 square somehow
corrode you oh but what's that aru
Hikaru was shaking his head cuz I'm
pretty sure work takes you to was
winning and he was unhappy but then
Wesley goes back to Rocky III to try to
hit g7 I think was he missed a move if
you alright the games gone but I think
was he missed a saving opportunity there
yeah I keep it why I can always pull up
the games I'll have to keep in mind Game
six because I think that there was a
chance that he could have survived
they're pretty easy to pull up a game I
have faith in you
but now we've seen if we wanted it we
got five minute portion it's our
opportunity to look at things like this
so what was the move
yeah I thought here is it said Brooke
one - f - maybe nephron Knight takes F
to a vroop g3 pending g7 throne a queen
g6 check I think that's actually that
may have been saving the game yeah but I
think Hikaru as he was shaking his head
cuz I think he missed work takes g2
perhaps but okay alright back to the
game we'll find out later but we have a
new new approach here from mokoro we
haven't seen mainline efore by him yet
we've seen Knight of 3 and b3 and all
kinds of other stuff a g6 coming ok
isn't mine the capture on d6 thing if f4
I'll take yep another biggest deal in
the world but generally speaking when
these double bonds are on f3 f2 you
don't want a lot f4 to happen so you
wanted to play at g6 top 5 yeah instead
of castles back here this is Robert's
point you got to use your positional
edge while you have it make it difficult
at least for white to fix the structure
y can play for c 3 and d 4 and and it's
still roughly equal but I agree I mean
now hey Carl looks to be comfortable and
sorry we were distracted about all the
missed wins but if we talk about last
game Hikaru just won and leveled it up
right so Wesley as you said has won all
the 5 minute portions including the
matchup that he lost last year to Magnus
Carlsen but uh but okay I mean Hikaru is
maintaining pace with Wesley and if the
time controls get faster and that proves
well for Hikaru then he may have done
his hardest work here in the 90 minutes
of 5 minutes yes yeah and shifted she's
made a great point about what her cars
openings have been yeah every game with
white is an early
interesting yeah something that we've
noticed but we guys didn't put the
concept together but yeah yeah with a
lot of these beef three openings he's
been trained the Queen's King ani - now
the Queen's are gone early in this
exchange Spanish so I don't know that
that's favoring him here I think Wesley
has equalized pretty quickly here again
I think we are
I don't know that Accardo has gotten a
lot with the white pieces so far I don't
think he has he just did not seem to
like was he's moved there yes I think
it's a perfectly fun it's an aggressive
move for black I mean I think maybe
black could also have just sat tight
this is a more committal move and not
Robert huh
hey Carla's gonna try to take advantage
of it I think a five try to put up
Bishop me to open space right yep so if
you can't go f5 because the e6 check
comes in and then pain though instead
this line makes much more sense and I
can come to g6 but in your future I
don't have any problem with wuzzies
position whatsoever you know you have
open up the bishop but you also have
creative weaknesses f3 in HD right - I
pawned your f4 I'd go pink Knight g6
well maybe shout-out to Andres fan 987
who just gifted a diamond membership
over in the chest TV game shot - wow you
are weak so that's an interesting
username to give it to but you like to
shout out the gifted subs on Twitch and
I'm a big part of the community there
but shout out there to the the holiday
gift of a diamond membership there from
ondrea's all right here comes the rook
to e6 and then f5 maybe h6 Falls rookie
six will take on that for I guess we're
just gonna trade then yeah I'll go
straight happy to trade you would be
happy to trade it's trying to hold on
what what you got I said should I
remember that what love and is it what
you got we're seeing different songs oh
I was thinking sublime and I rock a new
different tune right now that's been all
day we have not been quite simple codes
I think you have said this is our final
day it is our final day you're going
home after this yeah UK that's why I
went out of a way to make sure you got
your nice breakfast yogurt parfait I'm
doing okay you can cry it so it's but
not on camera
yeah here's making me sad baby all right
well Hikaru is gonna have to deal with
the kingside come in here yeah rook of
three check and then probably rook f2 is
gonna be a problem for Carl yep rook up
to you you can even get made it if you
if you do silly things just to show it
just to show hey on the board because we
like check my shout out to chest BAE
there with the gifted sub in the twitch
chat all right
the card was not gonna allow that mate
to happen King g4 maybe yet even four
pairs Bishop g4 Robert yeah you kick
that night and then the rook can
infiltrate this way I guess the question
is rook F - you've rookie 7 check but I
don't I think that works out because
after rook up to 7 charge go King G 6
shout out to Wagamama TV who says he'll
miss us soon - can I just say that it's
been so great to have you tuning in to
all of all of our World Chess
Championship coverage and now the the
speeches championship it's just amazing
you've got a lot of dota fans and we're
just so thankful that you've been a fan
of chess this month and then we got a
whole lot of gifted subs coming in so
we're feeling the love and we love all
you and go over to twitch.tv slash
wagamama TV if you're a DOTA fan and now
you got a DOTA chess streamer or chess
fan to fall I don't I don't think
wagamama has been streaming any chess
but he has been watching this month oh
look at this Knight G - coming yeah he
won or e3 oh I love it Knights coming to
G to e 1 and Hikaru
despite winning that H pawn has some
things to worry about
we got more more tweets coming in about
the daily question we'll get back to
those in a second let's follow this game
here to the to the to the exciting
conclusion and then we'll invite all of
you to keep getting involved here with
the daily question h4 don't okay don't
know because the cars are trying to run
the King to the Queen side yeah the
usage phone is a decoy but I don't know
if you're in time because night b4 is a
pretty big threat
yo get both the pawn so if you king of
594 but Bishop t2 of a smart very smart
move and that's how the Bishop flexes
its muscles over the night in these end
games by quickly switching and look at
this position everyone the bishop to d2
stopped Roberts threat but still
prevented the King from coming forward
so that's very nice Egham technique by
Hikaru but now he's a little nervous of
king e5 yeah c5 and I'm thrown a knight
to D through he went f5 that's probably
better because
93 was check and the other flies have
five now you can go d4 yep
and there no no 90 check for King the
King on e5 and the pawn on b2 nice point
Robert and the car needs to keep as many
persons thank you thank you for the
compliment Hagar I need to keep as many
pawns on the board as possible in the
Queen's I you don't want to trade now
the knight to sacrifice yep and then you
know you're not left enough material
they're having all three pawns remaining
is a big benefit to the wind chips no
it's a great point I know we got
distract a little bit there because of
the awesome generosity and wagamama and
the twits yep but this is a really
instructive endgame to see how the
bishop can help play the night and and
exactly why you favor that minor piece
in this type of setup Wesley going into
a think here for a good reason because
this is kind of his last moment Robert
to come up with some sort of blockade
right some sort of defensive setup
because hey karo is an endgame he's good
at end games and especially these types
of in games would require a lot of pure
calculation right now he knows how to
calculate as we know he knows how to
have the right setups to create the best
winning chances look at this technique
bishop guarding this square the king is
just doing everything it can to prepare
to put on the running shoes and get over
here to the Queen side yeah some people
put on their blue suede shoes
although hikaru has sung Elvis before on
a stream I've heard actually yeah no
legit Hikaru Hikaru sings sometimes on
his stream which makes me feel better
because he car was a singing voice if I
may be so bold isn't that's any better
than mine okay for sure
a4 nice move again hey karo just working
it on both sides of the board here with
no diggity here comes the King I love
this end game just cuz it's so
instructive I think I'm trying to figure
out a way for black to even try to hold
here you can't go a five cuz Bishop d2
comes yep and your a5 palm I just be
lost in there it goes I guess if Bishop
d2 you can go Knight e too but thing is
the Knights can't lose Tempe right so
after Bishop d2 yep if you go Knight II
- I can't just let Bishop to e3 yep and
then I'm my king is eventually gonna
make its way right there and I can't
come to see one to attack b b3 okay
Bishop guards it yep but no but you're
right in fact that's that's like a whole
nother end game lecture you and I give
but there's this
oh wait let's analyze this before we
mentioned the trip I was mentioning the
triple step method by the bishop to get
so long but okay let the b5 is so last
chance it Carlos gonna think and there
may be some weird way the night gets
trapped in some of these positions to be
very careful about moves like Bishop d2
you could be to square to escape to I
guess the question is if Bishop b2 now
if we start with Bishop d2 are you gonna
sacrifice your knight is that possible
yeah well you could you I don't think
you can't I don't think you can think
it's too slow yep just a show I mean
okay there's different lines like this
but again it's just too slow and and
white can blockade all the pawns just in
time and kid take d5 next yep that's
that's all but it karo up on time and
that's critical because you need it to
calculate accurately in these last few
uh few critical moments and Wesley I
think playing the right approach with
beefed up whoa efore Wow just that talk
about the canto number 11 it's here hey
Carlo number 11 the calculation over the
shoulder that's nice yeah that's really
nice and well timed there Ricardo saying
I calculated this to the end Danny I'll
flash you number 11 speaking of 11
season 3 of stranger things coming out
different discussion later yeah it's
very different discussion yep what's my
car when was he sorry
you got me track there you go all right
okay so the point here is that if okay
if black had taken white would have
white would have rushed the a pond and
in this line what Carla's saying is I
think he's think he can stop the a pond
but this night can't stop mine and I
yeah I think that's exactly what he
calculated and and very important a very
that was a very risky concrete way to
play but he car Nakamura calculates with
the best of them and I think it's gonna
work out in fact now he can just play a
six yep you can also just take on c5
what that night get back yeah cuz then
c5 and b3 right but I think just a six
obviously he's gonna calculate it better
than you or I but yeah you go a six and
the point is that even after Paul
Young's d4 you can take back in the
bishop if you yeah and this Knight is
actually well it would be nice
works blundering everywhere you're tired
you've done a month of commentary young
man do not that's why he has to resign
it's May don't hae girl bouncing around
like he's been here before look let me
let me uh let me show the next game has
started but let me bring up the analysis
board here if I can I mean I got a I got
a I got to bring up the Carter's game
here cuz that's super super awesome to
show everybody yeah that was this ending
right here ends because after d2a eight
yes both sides get queens but Hikaru
calculated that in the end you actually
have made on h8 so there was no time
left for Wesley to get a queen and make
a race of it
wow what a very nice way to bring that
thing to a finish and for some reason
the live board has not been updated we
were still on the last game here in the
live board but hopefully we'll get that
fixed here interesting well there we go
there that was awesome yeah and it gave
everybody a last view thereof exactly
what Hikaru naka Morris calculation
skills are capable of yeah right you and
I were looking at and we were
highlighting the technique of the bishop
and the way to massage which was great
but a Cara once he had the Bruce for
brute force opportunity to play before
yep he just crushed it awesome no and
we've seen this before and you know I
see the check going crazy about stranger
things you know maybe Dave Harbor will
make his way into the chat and then we
could talk about his treatment of very
good things and that's what got it on
our mind today is our aren't in the
background came came bringing it yep
because he is a stranger thing yeah
aren't we all stranger things yeah you
know but no the that's a different
discussion thanks to everybody who's
with us whether your chest comp TV or
twitch.tv slash yes so I've been quite
fun here today Hikaru Nakamura has now
won two games in a row if you're just
joining us Wesley so was holding a free
games to two lead maybe just enough to
poke the bear hey Cara Nakamura has
rebounded here in Wesley Wesley needs to
do the same in the last 20 minutes here
right stop the bleeding compose himself
in five minute and at least level things
up before you get to the three minutes
yes yeah and this is gonna be a very
important game for Wesley because he did
bounce back he
was up early in the match you have lost
the game that he wanted game he's lost
two in a row you cannot afford a don't
want to lose three in a row his position
is very nice look at this ugly II
consummated her car I hate it oh wait
but why is he because he say c7 is weak
a3 is only slaves the threat I guess so
queen c4 Queen b3 stops black from
playing ePHI that's a great wait see
four actually might win a pawn is now II
five sir and Knight a5 is a second the
point here we wanted together again this
is pinned on that bug right that bug
that's just a and and if you leave the
Queen there here comes Knight f5 in fact
Robert just highlighted that pin and we
may see it because he Carlos played 97
but Wesley taking his time rook to c1 he
carted his credit has kind of been
stubborn in the black side of this
Italian here despite Wesley being better
we'll see if that pays off toward the
end of the match but Wesley has been
better with the white pieces in every
Italian we've seen so far
absolutely why didn't he go 95 instead
of rook c1 I know I liked your tactic
and I thought that's what we were gonna
say that pawn is pinned it's a fork oh
that strange working mode and no matter
where you go I wouldn't yeah I I wonder
if Wesley is his facial expression has
changed slightly would suggest to me
he's a little frustrated and why'd he
take on c7 there right and if you take
on c7 instead of retreating with your
Queen after an exchange of Queens yes
you win d3 but I'm throwing soon to go
to Knight is 5 so yeah this and this I I
agree with you I feel like what's these
edges still slight but you can't keep
saying things like yes I'm still better
but I missed this but I missed as
eventually that edge will just go and
now he's getting aggressive a for
different knight g6 it looks like you're
losing the F pawn but I guess iv5 first
and maybe 9 h5 is he really gonna put
the pony there I like that actually ok
hey George two guards before rookie 4 is
the best move ooh defending and
attacking yeah and he finds it ok so
Wesley
despite our small criticism there my
suggested maybe he's a little frustrated
looks like he's composed himself to have
an edge Hikaru mcaro either scowling
something or wishing he washed his
facial hair a little bit better maybe he
smells something I don't know what's
going on with that face right there but
I'll figure it out later
all right rook a5 he's trying to trade
b4 d yep but C is also a problem as well
how many times how many pawns gonna keep
mentioning before we say
make a coconut tree joke come on B + C
I've read that book to my daughter so
many times I do deserve a dad fail for
that I really take a Chicka Boom Boom
was right there on my - no mercy 5 and
whatever happened to did - D being
dragged up the coconut we don't to get
into that we don't want to get into that
but all right Wesley
he's uh what is he doing maybe he's
getting a little glare off of the
computer or a stroke missed on
calculating what seeing a brook uh yeah
sing a quick yeah yeah a quick gather
yourself find this n focus right I like
to think of Spira fingers anytime I get
nervous that's how I that's how I sent
her myself but just hanging yeah he
finds rook c6 and after 97 why can't
Wesley just take with either piece by
the way we nor rook Bueller Bueller I
don't have an answer for you jeweler so
I'm a Cameron from Ferris Bueller in
fact he takes with the Queen I like this
is great because now after Queen e6
rookie six trophy 595 is a taking
advantage of a pin Knight doesn't
mention f5 f6 is also good enough either
way Wesley here and this is a big game
for him because if he rebounds he's
saying look I'm not gonna go away either
right
I'll grab grab the the bull by the horns
both literally and figuratively
I love these just like lean back right
and akaru is just like the Brady Bunch
right hey Cara Vacarro Vacarro
yeah Marsha Marsha Marsha queen b5 by a
car interesting fine their desperation
yeah tonight at five is still strong and
if five looks good yeah f5 can't be bad
either just go f5 f6 and yeah when you
have a knight f5 that's the dirty girl
now you got many options this one's a
piece
whoa 97 rookie 7 the threes going for Oh
a little trick apoo wave rook takes d4
Harris but then the rook is still
number 64 either oh wait but the rook is
under fire now because the pawns gone
yeah I forgot that point
so wait that's why I robbed a robber
confused a 97 rookie 7 I don't know yeah
Queen c8 check maybe this okay you in
the end you have this check and push 6
start with these six okay he's gone okay
cool obvious look at we figured it out
yeah but it was too hard so he didn't
figure it out for a while hey sometimes
just I've been giving myself credit I
keep my expectations very low on myself
and I feel like that was a win I like
what why mama TV just said petitioner
face cams on all speech has tourneys
ever in the future yeah we look we do
have it in every speeches championship
so wagamama if you if you became a fan
of the chess coverage because of the
World Chess Championship then maybe now
you'll keep watching this because this
is obviously V you know this is the
finals but that that's one of the cool
things about this format as you get to
have the direct connection with the
players emotions and all that stuff and
I've been I've been petitioning for a
Hikaru kam that just follows him
everywhere he goes in life for years
like somebody with a GoPro on their head
walks backwards and follows him wherever
for a good reason right so so I hear you
on the Hikaru cam what's I wonder why
mom like this is a restaurant wagamama
make me hungry always thinking about the
food yeah any time like have to talk for
hours I got a thing yep a queen of fate
idea be 78 yeah Queen just be careful
because rook b2
yeah he Caro has been known to swindle
himself a last-second perpetual and this
case no you know little front that was
that was the car number 14 as I've said
14 is living in the past it's not the
kind of hick horror face you want to see
if you're rooting for him now he's only
shown it a couple times today and now
we're gonna show a couple more tweets
here today because we haven't done
enough of that so we've got suggestions
for chess960 to come back have it be
played right before each section okay
that's that's a good suggestion I think
the SCC format as it is is pretty
awesome I just hope you'll keep the
standard chests separated from chess960
okay so there's a counteracting tweak to
that but I would love to see is
high-profile dedicated chess960
well I cannot I am not allowed to reveal
certain things right now because this
particular event still has a lot of
negotiations going on for those of you
that were here or following our producer
aren't on his own channel know that I
kind of I kind of let the cat out of the
bag about some events we're doing but I
can tell you there is actually a lot in
the works to to potentially make Fisher
random um make a big splash with
chess960 and if everything comes
together obviously you can read between
the lines and know that we covered a
certain event from oslo last year where
magnus carlsen took on a car Nakamura
and kind of the first ever unofficial
world chess championship for Fisher
random with those two guys and we're
we're working hard with some other
partners to potentially have more Fisher
random coming your way that's all I can
say all right what do we got we got a
game that looks like it's gonna be
boring so good time for me to go on a
tangent cuz this is just a quick draw
yeah I just find me because you keep
talking about yeah I shouldn't be
talking about it but you continue to I
didn't say anything no I know you didn't
come a little bit closer well I like I
like I've always been a tease my wife
just said that for years
hey Dad bud shuffle here alright I
didn't say anything
wait did I say anything no I didn't say
anything
hey nobody's clipping it sending it to
organizers and you said too much of
saying nothing yeah say no more
anyway back to the chest say my name
when I'm around you could still say baby
I love you here we go okay so the
dynamic here is Queen rook and five
apiece right so even material come
forward word but why has this work in
the seventh rank which looks really nice
the flip side White's King is actually a
little bit vulnerable as well just
because you're not getting background
check mate doesn't mean that you don't
have weaknesses right we got so we got
diagonal problems yep yep and Riptide
played advantage of that a funny move
queen of seven hash tag puzzle rush yarn
just to point out that you can't
actually you can't do that and it's fine
but you can't take I was gonna say that
one first we can't take the rook can't
take the rook because then you get made
it but queen of seven is it's actually
not the worst move even based on the
fact that we don't expect black to
checkmate himself
it's actually pretty interesting move
and he doesn't wait are you look at
puzzle brush paint off me yeah I'm gonna
can I drop the mic and retire now should
I call you you leave you don't even know
okay nickname you puzzle rush Nakamura
there you go right the first step is
admitting you have a problem first step
toward recovery yep
you're never gonna recover so okay we'll
get back to a question about what is
Fisher random versus just 960 a minute
the short answer is they are the same
thing just different names and hey
somebody screwed up the branding
originally that's all it is
but queen of seven was played and the
point again
is the battery on the seventh ranked
very powerful there are also potential
back rank issues that so has to figure
out in a car wants to have an edge
heading into the rook ending because if
the Queen's are traded now the seventh
rank becomes the overarching storyline
not the weak King that you highlighted
Robert and also I think was this
calculating the King and pawn and game
as well scepter takes f7 this rook takes
d8 check that you were talking about
before we have to play Queen to g8
that's sort of ending where there's
majorities in different sides right so
if you're is it take on f7 yep rook d8
Queen I'm saying so it takes d8 oh I
thought you were going for the Brooke
ending okay well similar ideas you have
Paul majority's an opposite side of the
board yeah - for white in the Kings side
three-on-two for black on the Queen side
now in particularly king of pawning
games here comes the attention of the
king of money how card look da we'll see
they could get this position that's on
the analysis on the board here in a
moment it was gonna say Kings often are
tied to this majority side right so
right lives can get stuck on the King
side whites Queen King will be stuck on
the Queen side and you're in your aunt
and we're gonna see it and the reason
that is is because you're trying to
prevent your opponent from getting the
passport the pawns I highlighted and
we'll get back to the main game or in
this position here are the pretenders a
pretender is upon that is almost past
because it doesn't have anybody on the
direct file blocking it so the the C
pawn has no Challenger in orders the f1
okay we're having very basic stuff for
beginners but hopefully this is useful
for people watching as far as how you
would assess trades and transitions into
end games the ultimate goal is get the
more active King which Chikara was done
and be the first to create a passed pawn
which could happen here for Hikaru but
watch
for the long-term chances because even
if his three-on-two is slow Wesley still
has a pretender and that could become
dangerous later now everything we just
highlighted I think is instructive for
the viewers robber but like most likely
this game probably should be a draw
right with best play it should be I just
wanted to give an example of something
you should not do if you are yeah go for
it so let's say white goes h3 and just
played uh-huh and he goes he five okay
just trying to make a move in g4 yep
take stakes and g5 ignoring the fact
that loses a pawn Amelia but f5 check
yep now you have a protected pass pawn
that can't be challenged yep and that's
a big problem because now the white king
is free to go to the downside and I'll
just I'll show that on the board but
Robert saying is this King literally you
could put them in Chinatown over here
put them over here and no matter where
this King is blacks King is permanently
stuck it can never leave the F pawn but
it can also never get rid of the
defender yep so these are you know
things to keep in mind and look at how
well we've kind of predicted the flu I
mean this is like we keep highlighting
it thinking it's instructive fodder you
know casual talk pillow talk here
between the two of us but it's actually
become very useful because it's the kind
of end game we're about to see and watch
out cuz King before is met immediately
by pawn to b5 and sometimes your King
goes a little bit too far because now
once the King goes b4 and b5 happens you
have to go King stood back to c3 to get
back in the action will show it if you
want a king before I say oh okay I
thought you were saying I like that you
listen to majors only half of mine I was
attracted for a second before I forgive
you 5 now blacks Kings yeah now blacks
King is the more active one of the two
indeed but maybe I was instinctively
trying to play a better move it's
possible interesting all right no I
before I just take off basalt ALPA salt
yeah you can I get across all the side
of oppas Aquos all across all and after
King b3 King defies I'm going to gobble
up your King side pawns you would do
that you'd be a you're a big pond
gobbler okay well hey karo taken some
time here to make sure that those types
of things don't happen for a good reason
but uh he doesn't look particularly
thrilled yeah I think it's cuz he
thought he had winning chances here he's
realizing he's just gonna have to peer
it out that's the I'm slightly
wait
wait wait wait dumping of six instead of
king daeso you know yf5
he karo perked up because after f5 your
king is far away from the Queen side
Paul I didn't Wesley just go back I and
repeat I think he was worried about have
five happening anyway but he just had
that position excuse me wow this I think
f5 is just right and again you can't
play g5 we were just highlighting that
the beauty of a protected passer is this
king could be in any hemisphere of the
planet and blacks king is frozen in
prison if you will to the protected
passer so if that v is played which
Chikara was done Wesley had to take it
but now as I said it the first person
with a passed pawn especially if you
maintained the more active King you got
winning chances here is it gonna be
enough a car is shaking his head all
over the place and well not sure how
black defenses because even move your
King back let's teach her sharp for the
wedding in King f7 King g5 King a seven
that comes f6 check benson repeated car
looks like he knows how to usually very
little dandruff just tina d65 right just
throw your king in yeah sometimes you
you don't worry about the pawn yeah you
just didn't worry about the pawn to
decoy and go over to the other side yeah
because what he's doing actually
speaking of rinser piece is shouldering
the enemy king yep that's right
yeah I wonder what her car was preferred
shampoo is let's that's both these guys
after the game they do look like they
got a healthy head of hair as a guy was
born with a receding hairline I could
use some tips was he's not happy this is
an unfortunate situation for him right
now
because he needs to stay in yep time
he's only 5 minutes left if a carro wins
this game very likely we're still gonna
get one more game unless they somehow
milk another six minutes off this clock
but I doubt it but Hikaru managed to
work it with that five I'm surprised
Leslie played King of six rather than
king t6 which had already worked right
so you move here because c5 is the
last-ditch effort here but still the
king just goes to five and this is just
basic component game technique you use
the first pastor that's why we said you
want the first passer as the decoy for
your king right wait to shuffle in but
did Wesley calculate something just
kingi five king bee six king defore he's
getting there just in time king bee 5c4
eyes on time King takes does he have
king c5 we're draw no okay I'm puzzled
rushing this is there a weird swindle
draw he's going for at before it doesn't
work definitely doesn't work takes king
c5 King a5 and then a four in your
insects Wang yeah indeed Wesley agrees
he resigns and we have one more one more
game here left him he played likely
unless somebody loses in the next four
and a half minutes we have one more game
here in the five-minute portion before
we head to three minutes so to all
17,000 of you with us thank you for
being here don't go anywhere this is the
speech Chess Championship this is the
finals you're looking at the two men
atop of the bracket at the end of this
year's season the 2018 speeches
championship and uh Wesley back to the
Italian it's working for him karo has
something to prove here against this
very positional approach in the Italian
by Wesley yeah I really like what he's
been doing here and as we are in the
last game likely the last game of the
five minute yep segment and he'll have
of course an hour of the three-minute
portion which he has never lost three
minutes segment hey Carl
Wes has never lost a three-minute
segment of the speech s championship so
that is just why our pre match stats
kind of had him as a slight segment
favorite favorite in the three-minute
absolutely um so this is you know this
is only a one game match and based on
what we've seen from these players so
far a tug of war right Hikaru won two in
a row Wesley bounced right back
hey car overturned the favor so if
Wesley can keep pushing for an edge here
in this Italian even if he's not always
getting a decisive result that's right
where you want to be right pushing a car
Oh being a little bit better yeah and
the Italians always in style when it's a
lead level chest right they just play
for these small advantages we just try
to look at the position at large eight
pawns for both sides look at plants been
traded look at those black double ponds
right that's both a bad thing and a good
thing it's a good thing because it opens
the rook on f8 to send me open file it's
a bad thing because what del bones can't
protect each other yep potentially weak
as the game goes on yes and why can you
start taking an advantage
eventually playing d4 which undoes the
pollens but also gives way more space
yep so these are the things you really
have to think about but you
and you made a kind of an offhand
comment the Italians always in style for
top players and and and I think that's
because and you can add you know you're
the stronger chess player but it's
because of the flexibility it offers
both sides right that's why both sides
are willing to play it it's it's a pawn
structure with a ton of options you got
this break you've got the break and any
sign the queenside black has a lot of
maneuvering options both to try to I was
just highlighting that d7 and you plays
it and attacking chances here and it's
that why you we will never see the
Italian go away right just because both
sides both sides can play for a win so
to speak speaking of playing for a win
rook takes f3 here so tempting yeah I
was gonna wait to de Caro just bathroom
break akaru ask him but he's gone
maybe he anticipated that Wesley might
think a little bit bad timing or he you
know pizza guy's there maybe just you
know you know either way hikaru is gonna
get down on time in this game because
he's chosen for whatever reason to take
a break right here right now he's doing
he's let the dogs out because they
wanted to bark right they were barking
up a storm and someone's gotta let him
out so he carro goes to let the dogs out
he'll be back in just a moment we're now
joined by mr. duck lips akaru thanks for
being here buddy appreciate it but all
right back to the structures you said
there's a lot of flexibility for both
sides and you said that if a car wants
to play for a win he might look at rook
takes f3 so let's analyze that rook
takes a takes here
I guess not for it I mean yeah there's a
couple options but yeah little BT 3
probably other rook over right it's a
great compensation yeah maybe I can
throw it nope can't do that try go
Knight a5 but the problem night of 5 you
take advantage of a pin deep on just
lose but no you don't want to it with a
905 you might take with a rook on a 5
double exchange sad yeah because after
double rainbow no that could say 5 check
what you're not doing enough puzzle rush
Queen g5 check
oh it's mate it's not mate but well is
it anything though
maybe it's not you get a puzzle rush
don't call me out like that you know
darn well I'm wasting my life right now
Robert called me up for neglecting my
kids for puzzle rush last night well you
said you know I said you sound like an
addict I did at the time I was like hey
man you think we could squeeze in a
puzzle here before the kids get back
anyway if we hide in the car and
justjust rounds a puzzle roast that cool
okay well Carl's back it what's funny is
he's down in min on the clock and we
would sit here and describe a storyline
a fake heart thinking maybe he feels
worse but we all know and look at his
face he doesn't worse he he is worse but
it's funny he only lost 90 seconds
because he couldn't couldn't hold his
bladder apparently shoutout to
International Master Anna Rudolph back
on twitch after the World Chess
Championship coverage and of course he
asked her Sarah won the one the only
Grandmaster Caz we are about to be
headed to the three-minute portion so if
you're just getting here we still have
the majority of chess left to be played
it's been a very exciting match here as
you can see it is only a one game
separation and if Wesley so wins this
position where he is better we could be
all knotted up as we head into the three
minute guards position stinks right now
maybe the fact that he took that
bathroom break caused him to miss Rooke
takes up three right maybe he that's a
really bad timing yeah I got out of his
way he got out of his rhythm because he
came back very upset that he had lost 90
seconds and just didn't consider again
if you're just joining us we were
talking about this position where Hikaru
had the opportunity to sacrifice the
exchange and maybe really create some
practical wooden chances with the black
pieces but but now he's much worse
yeah his Ponzi seven has been a nuisance
from every single game and the blacks of
the Italian yep and he plays Queen up
six to hit the d4 pawn so Brooke takes
t7 he's like okay at least I can take on
d4 and I'm still not convinced that the
black yep
okay yeah and that's the way was it took
on e5 first saying I think we want to
give you that opportunity now what
Knight d4 do I take on e5 I have options
here I mean you're only 39 takes to f3
cuz I take admire yeah he likes your
mighty four move because this F five
squares calling his name Wesley Wesley
and the 95 it moves in fe5 check right
the King just moved off the back
let's show that because people love
discoveries it's a thing I've learned
and actually doesn't when you know the
Queen knows about anything but they
still love discoveries it's weird yep he
puts that night there you heard the call
the next ones coming to age five and and
c7 is officially hanging yet again in
that H five hits the Queen and the g7
pawn this is looking oh that's a that's
an awkward looking fork knights go wild
rated X edition GM Yasser Sara Juan just
subbed I was a gifted South by tag bond
thank you for that but we like to think
that if jazz was ready to he's gonna use
those emotes proudly thank you tomorrow
so work of seven defends he's just
taking his time here Wesley is just
again tryna make sure he squeezes but
the carro is gaining a little bit of
time back on the clock was down 90
seconds now only down a minute trying to
be aggressive over here so the car is
hoping to save this one this will be the
infamous bathroom save for around the
world if indeed he comes back yeah and
well the problem for black and his
comeback attempt is the 96 is stuck here
remember that night 95 comes in hitting
both the Queen and the c7 Paul yep and
oh and he goes for it right away because
the e4 square yep is now newly open for
business and he's not just trying it to
e-force when I get to g5 yeah II for is
a kind of a routing okay I can quaint it
whoops I was hogging my queen
we take g6 I was gonna say well you are
tired right now it's okay that was a
that was not ideal
you know blundering my queen like that
but I'll get over it I think 94 is
threatening g3 and then h4 and then the
knight comes in you have to be worried
about cheese because of Knight f3
obviously ooh Oh car is disgusted can't
believe he missed that move not only
cause rooks Ieva because Knight takes D
six is coming I love this comment here
bright a match s7 I thought an engine
doesn't need the bathroom
Arikara well b6 just completely missed
here by Hikaru was one of the concrete
frets about this night coming to e4 we
were kind of highlighting I guess the
night taking these
kind of routes but but d6 was actually a
tactic the moment that I came there and
what brought what Robert highlighted
about the d6 from being weak is that
this was a threat right away cuz the
pawn was pinned yep we didn't even see
that well that's actually what I was
gonna say befo under my queen yeah I
thought you highlighted see how
psychically now we're telekinesis coming
back homes yes sir I'm right I'm right
there wait your brain can you just take
this you think you can and you will and
so it's Queen B to the winning move here
hitting the knight and discover it no
not with just CD equals Queen rook f3
there's a lot of them see it equals
Queen is yeah and officially I believe
we are going to be tied indeed we are
Wesley so wins and guess what ladies and
gentlemen the speed chess championship
finals is gonna be all you hoped it
would be because we are knotted up after
the first portion this has been about as
close as anything we could have hoped
for
okay you're right well thanks for
helping me fall short but that hype but
no the the point is we have a lot of
action ahead of us it's everything you
hoped it would be and after a very short
break we are going to be right back with
free minute chess so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back everybody to the 2018
speech Chess Championship finals
grandmaster car nakamura taken on
grandmaster wesley so and we have all
that action in the three-minute just
ahead i want to take a quick second to
remind you why robin her and i look so
good in these blue shirts the pro chess
league is the next big thing happening
in the world of online chess really the
next big thing in twitch you can forget
twitch rivals and fortnight them in case
you were wondering now you got the memo
the protest league is where it's at
thirty two teams come together to battle
for big prizes from all around the world
and the 2019 campaign is about to begin
for all of them grandmasters that have
been joining us in the World Chess
Championship coverage like Sam Shanklin
obviously Wesley so joined us and he's
playing today
Hikaru Nakamura for the Seattle sluggers
and two guys that were actually playing
in the World Chess Championship they'll
also be playing in the pro chess league
including none other than the world
chess champion Magnus Carlsen so quick
shout out also there are extensions over
the viewer if you're watching at twitch
there is a one click button to go to
twitch.tv slash pro chest league and
give us a follow as well as robin on our
personal channels as we make new year's
resolutions to really bring robert's
streaming game way up and he's gonna be
a lot more active on his channel you
want me to call you out like that on
camera hurt alone okay well I was about
to say that hurt but you know I meant it
nobody's gonna say it's because you know
I'm always better when I'm doing comedy
with you which means on the officials
chest channel which would just show my
channel so just true that's true
I was trying with myself as a team and
you trying to bring me that I was not I
was not as I was saying that because the
people want to see you anyway but people
also want to see three-minute they've
had enough of us we are about to have
liftoff here we go
tide match speed Chess Championship
finals I can't wait to see what these
guys bring us three minutes yes ahead
and let's waste no time so a car go back
to what we saw in Game one this is what
he okay not exactly the right move over
but he did start with d4 Knight f3 in
Game one if you missed that and but now
we have a much more straightforward
Queens gambit position on the board than
what we had in Game one but here he goes
this is gonna be another D take C for
thing happening nope no Bishop takes e5
he's welcoming the iqp car who gives a
slight nod that's a car number three a
very very slight kind of over the
shoulder nod they're not quite sure he
was it means I just wasn't
affecting it I'm still very comfortable
though yeah and white is doing perfectly
well it's the at me stage of the game
but I think was he feels comfortable in
the Black Studies as well the big
difference here in the extra tempo right
it's a completely symmetrical pollen
structure all pollen to the same exact
squares yep and the bishop wants c8 just
like the bishop on d2 can go to that
square right from the core I think that
black isn't perfectly fine early in this
b6 should be seven again Wesley was fine
in Game one as well and gonna be about
equal you know the position is very
level it's a both sides are gonna put
their rooks on these files and you know
usually one tactical slip away from
losing but otherwise you see a lot of
just equal chess here on this type of
pawn structure you're wondering how to
follow the channels that we just hyped
hold your mouse over the analysis board
on the stream you see on the on the
twitch player and click on those
extensions to instantly follow the
protest League as well as Robert in my
channels there so where you can see more
commentary alright the transition of the
double pawns is common in this pawn
structure especially cuz you always have
the bishop on the night of three but it
doesn't mean it's really enough for an
edge at all in fact white white can
often use these double pawns to his
advantage right because they hold off
critical squares right Robert yeah for
sure and I was just looking at the
graphic pulled up here about the odds to
win the match when two become one
Wesley Sona Cara Nakamura are are that
closely tied here right you see a car
was the blue line but his face is
currently covered up by the adorable
Wesley so is that Diego from Dora the
Explorer of Wesley so you tell me looks
like was he so to me but I also don't
have four kids and don't watch or the
explore all the time well we may just
get a peaceful result here since not the
most of the most exciting Whitney she
and Society of these players has ever
had but no Hikaru wants more again I
think that's what he needs to do as the
time controls get faster continue to
push these positions to where both sides
are playing on the clock yeah and Hikaru
believes that his biggest advantage
comes in the bullet portion right so he
might as well milk this game clock and
so there 57 minutes up in this
three-minute portion and that time
actually takes down pretty quickly when
the
long yeah it's not the five minute
anymore right we're not in Kansas
anymore yeah so essentially like you can
chop a lot of time off that clock and
even if he's down one game after this
time segment he still feels probably
very confident in bullet right we know
that Hikaru is he's a he's a bullet
beast but okay now that he's pushed this
one you know again for the clock which
again I feel from a match strategy is a
good one by Hikaru because of what we
know he can do in time scrambles but I
wonder if you should just repeat here no
he doesn't okay so cuz I don't think he
has anything but a potentially worse
endgame now Robert given that Wesley has
successfully lifted the rook the
elevator will always afford access to
the weak pawn over here on the Kings
side how is he Cara playing for a win in
this end game now right I mean I think
black is the only one who has a slightly
better structure I wouldn't be surprised
with car losses that's what I'm saying
right so I was I was kind of promoting
hey I think that's a good match strategy
for Recaro to get things on her time
screw in time scrambles but but if he
doesn't repeat now I know he doesn't
okay I think he's saying that he doesn't
actually run any risk of losing his
position she as wears black an attack
you in order to put a pressure on this
age phone which is an isolated pawn you
to get your rook and your knight over
there we drive so much time as your
Queen's I will be in trouble but wuzzy
doesn't have to do much to hold the
balance here you can just shuffle back
and forth now okay 92 allows rook c2 so
he didn't want to get super aggressive
but rook c2 felt like a good move maybe
we should worry about 94 because there
were no immediate follow ups and I think
that was smart by a car normally if you
have that type of endgame and you just
take 40 seconds off the clock for each
player yeah right same exact setup but
40 more seconds off the clock that
that's an endgame that Accardo might
swindle his way to a victory we should
remember to ask that question in the
about Game one of the three-minute
portion so it's writing out loud yeah
you have my diary I don't have my diary
I speak out loud to myself also I've
heard it's healthy but my therapist
tells me yeah okay alright so yeah the I
just want you to be healthy mentally
roughly both and also chess wise looking
at everything yep well okay
Wesley wants everything here he's gone
he's gone full center played Bishop d2 I
don't know why he's taking his time but
he is well cuz he keeps putting his rook
on e to it he likes this rook there it's
a consistent idea I guess in this
Italian structure to have this ability
to flip the rook to the Queen side I'm
learning something by watching these
guys play high quality chess you just
keep the rook on the boat it's a for
hanging yep okay so what if I just comes
back and says doubled pawns or not I
guess why just one one and this is
actually going to be very quick
conversation if the knight can go from a
Cho to f4 but Knight g3 exactly stops
that yep
planning his tracks and now there's a
big problem here how are you gonna get
full compensation pump there should be
three comes Queen d2 can come next king
h1 work to g1 okay I was gonna be
aggressive to try to stop it but you
made a great point that this was a car
was playing to bring to bring the two
knights in on this outpost Square
everyone but but Wesley accurately just
putting all these plans on the
backburner and now he's just clearly
better again in the Italian I mean I
don't even know what a car his plan is
now because Knight to d7 obviously the
cream of a children Knight f5 is always
a possibility but can you I guess Knight
a5 Queen g4 check is he trying to do
something like that no it doesn't I
guess I barely what are you suggesting
which would Knight f5 or White Queen g4
check and I guess that for pawn is fine
I thought that I would be able to get
away with something right
I don't so which makes was he's move
just perfectly good Queen e2 right just
guard everything and and continue yeah
now Knight f5 could be a threat yeah
some positions or or King f1 ropes you
wanna I think yours is more accurate you
even f3 is a possibility I wouldn't go
have three because it opens up the
diagonal but that's a nice move cuz it
kind of stops king h1 with this awkward
Queen coming into f3 you have to be
really careful because there was an
awkward threat of Queen of three and
nine h4 with NATO they do look at this
move if Queen takes f3 you play a bit
overworked f2 and of Queen g4 only move
Bishop e2 we naitch for only move Knight
off
five and all of a sudden it's very clear
who's gaining the benefit from oh it's
cool I haven't even better idea maybe
after Queen City what if I hear school I
thought was gonna play Brooke g2 and
slowly-slowly do this but no now Roachy
- I was just trying to slow play the
idea because this attack is just gonna
get nuts yeah this actually where's the
screen guard from g4 maybe this is the
right way to go your total combination
of your idea and was it looks super
promising yep I mean now just okay
rookie G to the queen is like a trap you
might get trapped over there 905 might
also do the trick
but I felt like we g2 was just more
patient he said oh nice you're I could
not wait to get you on a plane I'm gonna
fill you up good make sure your belly's
full get you on a plane and send you
home 97 check-ins a night on g6 a car
who told me yesterday that if I didn't
send Robert back to his mother he was
calling the police
me realize I don't I know but your mom's
in New York yeah that's true you know
okay 90 97 wins the exchange but black
has some compensation but does you have
compensation that's the question what
does he do next time actually you
tonight she said yeah Knight takes h6
whence the Queen yeah I said Knight
takes rook oh yes you do Knight takes
Asus just wins the Queen straight-up
what yeah you were your he just missed
that he isn't been doing a puzzle rush
we know Wesley Wesley has not been doing
as much puzzle rushes akaru
this just won the Queen hello McFly okay
well hey car was still in the game at
least cuz Wesley missed that oh it looks
really yeah it's still very very tough
for a car though and and I think okay
we're we're having fun here highlighting
the tactics but again the storyline for
me that if we're making notes about what
we're gonna ask these players about is
if a car was sticks with the Italian and
continues to get in trouble like this
you know is that it was at a match
strategy to Dakar prepare the Italian
for Wesley
because he certainly isn't pivoting away
from it and he has been worse in every
game is black and we're not saying that
with any bias and he karo has not done
well in the Italian so far in this match
yeah no I don't like the decision to
continue sticking
that when he's getting his force
positions every single game and here
he's down in exchange okay he's hoping
for some tactile counter play Knight g4
as an idea wait
IG for is coming actually IG did you
like you for is it wants to be on the
board
I guess rook up and this move more
despite it being surprising maybe c4 was
actually even a better move in that g4
the more I think about cuz Leslie has to
give back some materials bishop
maybe Bishop c4 to keep that guy out Oh
keep keep this Ponce right where he is
yeah he likes it yeah it's gonna be
obstacle i bishops and we saw Bishop c4
on the board and thread is to go d6
right and so e5 is also possibility
coming yeah because we were talking
about how we they played the Italian and
the Italian happened and what as it
keeps happening we're gonna see a
carcass inside joke is gonna get real
out of control here real quick we are do
you want here Bishop g1 and it wouldn't
be surprising that it's on the board
because here comes the Queen over 2g two
cards facedown
so so wins by resignation and okay back
to the chest what we have here is six
and that five and a fleet of lead for
Wesley so who again has never lost the
three-minute portion in his history here
of the speeches championship so he
thought was so so that is so Nakamura
though to make a comeback after you've
lost a game and I wouldn't be surprised
if a car bounces right back here so now
a car were playing an Italian structure
is white slightly more open version of
it right but the Karem may be thinking
that's working for Wesley maybe all uh
maybe I'll do it too
yeah that car wasn't expecting this
night a seven move you could tell about
his face he's so demonstrative right but
he just let it be known but I think he's
still better he's definitely better
right yeah more space than iron g3 you
can go to f5 or efore even h5 in some
variation
and look you can take on c4 but it's all
about the quality pieces looked at 9a 7
that's a donkey yep
that's not a nice that's a donkey where
Shrek I'll tell you the rook is Shrek
where's the dragon we this is an opening
welcome back to that later but ya know
the donkey trying to improve itself but
very nice move Knight f5 threatens
things like Queen g4 so black tries to
get rid of that pony ASAP good ship g5
is a weird move but maybe deucing
inducing f6 is helpful because it would
kind of force f6
there's also moves that are sort of
simple like rook t1 if you allow the
bishop for Bishop endgame Accardo I
don't think it's happy that this night
is gonna have to be traded I mean you
can see he's he was really getting
excited for the King side attack and I
don't think it's happening K he goes
with the move I thought but what's he
gonna do 1 of 6 maybe just o rook t1 but
it if after the trade 7 right just and
takes here you have Queen e6 right
that's what he would like to have happen
but what if blood she was Queen e7 now
yo I don't think and Louis Lee does it
and the bishop can back up to c1 but
it's uh you know nothing special here
for Hikaru go Bishop e3 just to have
some tricks up his sleeve if was he's
wondering because Brooke musica Rick d8
and after Bishop d6 yep right meaning
everything perfectly or Bishop e6 Bishop
c7 but okay but I can try to make some
progress in a position like that so I
wrote d2 not sure about that one
no II for blunt is a 5 on e4 a5 very
nice there's also Bishop e6 threats
especially if you can double rooks right
and one of the biggest reasons why white
wants to double rooks here everyone is
because then the bishop can't move
without rook d7 and that's harsh yeah so
Wesley wants to get that Queen out of
there now maybe he can play Bishop c7
and offer in exchange kind of fight over
the D file the long term aspects of this
position are a little worrisome for
Hikaru because blacks 4 on 3 is a little
healthier and
White's four-on-three over here right so
it can actually maybe mobilize itself
f-5e for that corner that kind of thing
yeah and the downside of pushing those
pauses maybe you leave your cards
overextended you open up your King yeah
pawns can become weak kind of quickly so
it to be careful before that yep yeah no
this is okay this is probably going to
peter out into an equal any but you have
to be careful for black rights Queen to
b6 now is a threat so is in 287 look at
it was he getting active first of Queen
b6 b6 Queen c1 well there's no force
draw their queen c1 King age o check I
have g3 because the clean guards f2 yep
and that's you can take very nice at
Palma checks I would go King e6 there it
is yeah okay nice move by Wesley now of
Queen to be seven we will just have a
perpetual the Queen comes to f4 and back
to C 1 and and it's gonna be a draw in
fact at karo knows it kind of shakes his
head and actually just offers the draw
because he knows he got away from him so
Wesley bending off an Italian position
where he was a little worse and back out
of here and again I I think at this one
it has to be a question in the postgame
coverage regardless of even whether
Hikaru you know makes a comeback and
wins but he's down a game and he's been
consistently in just bad positions on
the black side of the Italian yes time
and time again we've seen was they play
this and get great positioning yep he's
a great feel for positions I guess
that's the most important he plays the
English is white he plays efore he likes
these positions that give him a degree
of flexibility right but sort of like
one-sided flexibility he could maneuver
and blackest a bit sit a bit passively
yeah car playing a5 this time I think
you know I want to be have some activity
on the queenside who at a four yeah he's
gone all in on that it's an aggressive
idea to try to make sure this be pong
becomes a target but the a pawn can also
become a quick target as well right by
having a pawn a for as rookie you want
to just play it maybe eventually be fork
if for pawn yes quite vulnerable it's a
weird position because if white goes
full defense mode and tries to hold the
b5 phone then black has d5 in some
positions and that and that can kind of
undermine the sea or an e4 pawn so okay
now we're just gonna get a trade I know
you can't take a four because then rook
takes b1 just win
yokas queen 67 Brooke take see one is
check check that's called a sufficient
sook if you speak German chess
terminology what does any was he just
plundered I think he did yeah what if
you just straight-up blundered that pot
oh my god I was highlighting the
instructive speech on zhuge but uh but
it was just a blunder in Hikaru finally
getting a position where black is better
in the Italian came with a plonker but
he needs it and he should win because of
the position but I really mean he should
win because the match situation yeah he
needs to level things up here he's down
a game if he can even it up it just
makes it much more difficult for Wesley
to enter the bullet yep and that's where
we keep going back to yes hit car was
the heavy favorite but was he is it
pretty talented both player himself but
just you just separate himself but it
wasn't needs to do is get it one turn
that one game lead by the end of this
but it didn't did you think before the
match that we would have this type of
discussion what Hikaru needs to do to
equalize it out right he's the favorite
by statistics and most human being
perspective but here if you're just
joining us we have a we have a dogfight
here maybe hey Carl let the dogs out too
early and now they're fighting but yeah
we have a battle and it is a one game
lead currently for the underdog Wesley
so I definitely actually expect this I
really thought that was they can compete
for sure with Hikaru in the longer time
so she was pretty level mattress 76 one
game difference here but I think that it
when all is said and done the bullet
will dictate what happens here and if
was he can hold on in the bullet section
he'll win this match
if Hikaru does what we know he's capable
of he should win the match right but
right now he cars there's not an easy
position for him to win because yes he
is up a poem but look at the beef iPod
look at the l5 pawn yep and if you see
what you play Ricky it he just did now
he looks a little tied down yeah and I
was gonna say why can play rook c3 Queen
B for hold back the C pawn now that's
backward so you're right this is a
position where black is still better
I mean blacks up a pawn but it's not so
clear how how white or how black has a
clear plan to win an out rook c5
rook to c8 preparing to push c5 so of
white wants to say no no suit for you
I'll put the rook there myself and hit a
five and b5
protect both that's a that's a poly it's
an interesting pawn to give up though
because this rook will be awkward for a
few moments and maybe there's some
tactical consequences ooh 9:05 though
the rook wants to come into the D file
oh I like that McCarter shaking his head
doesn't agree that doesn't agree with
his pawn sacrifice for the D file now in
hindsight and that move is nice just to
nail our Queen trade because what car
was hoping for is to trade Queens
yes material okay that's a horrible
sorry I was gonna try to do something
that showed showed the idea because even
though it's even material her car would
have just such an active rook potential
of coming to the second rank and
definitely winning chances in the
endgame yep
and now Queen d2 is met by Queen takes
c6 so that's why a car just slid is
Russia but but now maybe the knight
comes back to a5 we got threats on e7
and some 35 looks perfect yeah and he
does it also rookie sevens a big threat
in addition in the l7 rookie 7 hits
Queen e8
yeah but ever undone pins it the car is
wiping sleep from his eyes rook takes
the 8 o F for ponts hanging I want to go
rook e8 98 Queen takes c6 ah but Queen
takes a 4 at the end right that's that's
my problems let's put and we should show
it right so it takes if if Queen c6 I'm
threatening if you take on c6 then I'm
Knight check for keys a queen takes f4
maybe that's gonna Knight g3 back and
say your knight on the eights under fire
and your pawn on b5 and your king also
threading Queenie so interesting takes
ok that's step one they'll be 5 here as
well yep ok now Queen 66 66 is a fork I
missed it look at that Oh super
frustrated but he still actually has a
probably really good chance to yeah
because he's got that two-on-one yep and
so 995 as a threat both the f4 pawn and
pawn to b4 just push that's that's
really what this comes down to is and
we've said this many many times so I
just who's quicker in the endgame yep
and now after g4 black will go 95 the
same idea as to grape care I don't care
about don't know how many pawns you have
it's who gets a queen first yep and in
black surprisingly
he goes for us black surprisingly may
actually still be better here
despite the pawn blunder it's a huge
race though this is weird very weird
this is this is very similar to actually
the Magnus Carlsen game one victory in
the rapid over Fabiano car one exactly
Brooks this is bad for a car now he left
upon becoming a protected has gone and
now tonight before covers a two you may
still have g6 by the national King g3
right and I'm not in time to get tactics
okay so he's gonna play h5 first this is
I think it's already a losing position
for a card Wow and that would be the
first first two game lead we've had for
anyone if Wesley so wins this game I
think that would be the first we can
have our first two game lead of the
match for anyone and again with a
surprising surprising story line here
that Wesley so is really putting a car
Nakamura to work yeah and a car might be
tired he's playing in Italy you know
maybe some gen light but also what time
is it there now probably almost midnight
I don't even know 11 I stopped keeping
track of global time things the carro is
is definitely frustrated asking himself
what am i doing needs to pull it
together he knows that he's so upset am
i laughing at him because he's upset it
just I love that he's just so honest
about how he feels and here he's just
resigning quickly moving on needs to
bounce back and he had a two-game lead
here for Grand Master Wesley so this is
going to be down to the wire especially
because so many people know what a car
Nakamura is capable and bullet yep so
this is what Wesley so needed to do I
think to give himself a chance to win it
and a chance to win the match he does
have Yoda yeah thank you and the car
start with d3 in this game so I thought
he was just gonna venture into just
unchartered territories but right he
goes right back into a continue almost a
mouse love you makes you wonder
yes I was wondering but I think you're
just trying to get into this position
and look how fast he's moving but maybe
he's realizing that was he is not going
to break he's been a couple times he's
lost some games but was he's playing
extremely well yep
so if he just came pressure
the clock maybe that's his best chance
of winning because we still in the World
Championship right when two of the top
players in the world play the likely
result to draw in classical time right
but sort of the same holds true in let's
just the position will be relatively
level right but who's playing better
that day and also who can pressure the
other player in the clock so I think
well I think your karo also knows that
when he's playing his best chess he's
often playing very fast right I mean he
and I talked about that at the Isle of
Man the video we have it's on YouTube is
on twitch here but I asked him some
questions about you know where he's had
some struggles this year and he talked
about he's often taking more time before
he's about to make bad moves right and
this game here given that he's now up on
the clock maybe he just like hey hey
karo speed up right giving himself a pep
talk trust yourself and just move
quickly because right now we have those
those dancing heads moving a different
direction than most people expect it
with Wesley so moving up and in our
predictions as potential odds to win the
match at this time so kind of exciting
stuff maybe cuz we watched that Charlie
Brown movie O'Day but flying a kite I
see oh yeah a car Roberts been watching
a lot of movies with my with my two
youngest kids so he says we watched
Charlie Brown he forgets he watched
Charlie Brown and I was you know doing
other things
hey I think I was doing the kitchen at
that time I think you were but yeah the
UH okay but hey karo knows what he's in
for here and he's still very very fast
and very good at what he does so a
victory is needed here you don't want to
lose three games in a row and both sides
are actually waiting for the exchange
happened because your car once was he
taken to e3 so you can see back with a
knight and throw his eye into the d5
square Wes he wants a car take on c5 so
his knight improves in one turn look d5
it ends up turn nine f6 906 but yeah it
just seems like a simple way to defend
so again I think a car is kind of
miscalculating some tactics here you can
play coin to c4 by the way that might be
an interesting idea as if the knight
takes the rook you check back with the
pawn and or chemo
so he doesn't go for that that was an
interesting way to try to keep the fight
for the D file alive but in karo
surrenders the D file and and Wesley
kind of slowly working his way back into
a g6 guards f5 yeah I mean here cars
still ahead on the club remember that
much like twenty seconds and was he's
raiding just cross the three thousand
it's exactly three thousand yeah and
that's actually an you know an
achievement for Wesley because he is a
very active player on chess calm and he
cares about his rating and normally not
rocking above 3,000 at least as often as
a karo who still is above 3,000 despite
losing the last two so let's see how can
the karo make any progress here efore
under attack can you defend that ID to
would be a huge blunder what does that
okay I was about to highlight 192
would've been a huge blunder and instead
he was night chief so ok you fives
hanging keep an eye on that right maybe
he what's the H file it's not getting it
it's King g7 just closes that side down
yeah there's nothing nothing over there
the defaults already a problem that now
92 is a huge blunder once again cuz rook
takes d2 you don't want to allow tactics
to ruin your set okay look at this
position for black right black is
turning things around again okay Carl
going for counter play willing to give
up the chief war pawn in order for
access to the Queen side and maybe the
light squares and he goes for that Chuck
he's gonna take and then I like that
King but I was worried that there be
more tactics with the King on like these
diagonals and checks over here but okay
but you keep your knight protected right
so that's it might save you a critical
tempo - yeah good point especially if
the Queen's come off the board your king
is also closer to being in the center
okay I want to play g5 here very risky
move but I find g5 I can put my knight
on g6 next for black and then throw in
the night at four cuz your pawn G
through his pin there it is g5
it's getting very tricky position here
the Queen takes a five I guess Knight g6
just looks yeah just running 904 or was
gonna have to take a moment to make sure
he can allow that either that or he may
go for Queen c5 which pins the knight
and threatens the C pawn
that might be a smart move c5 because
the extra pawn isn't so meaningful here
yeah the pressure is in fact if you can
get this and maybe get your own work in
the game without without efore falling
so quickly
that's an idea no he takes it he decides
he can get away with this so he's gonna
call the bluff of 96 you know cuz you
know he's got Queen 67 coming
all right well oh not h2 akaru
calculating his way into defending those
threats now he gets Queen c5 and even a
5 is coming he karo has found his way to
be better in the endgame and this is
gonna this is a big game right here they
like if it karo can weather the storm
despite his frustrations of the last two
games it would be huge here comes an
icon oh that might go to h6 to f5 Knight
16 Queen semi and Queen J is great yeah
look at that call my name Hikaru I want
you on the square this is weird you have
a queen of cheesenut by rookie - I think
a car weathered the storm yeah Brooke F
ones and I mean everything's happening
here k goes to e3 it come to f5 d1 yep
that's that sounded like a little there
wasn't a lady who swallowed the fly goes
to e3 to come to f5 and now I've got a
skewer on the line this match is almost
tied yeah I think I think what's the
Dover sign here and we move on Wow big
win there big win there for a car
Nakamura didn't expect that to happen
because yeah Leslie was the one who was
better in a certain moment and the car
really got nothing yep their early stage
of that game but a huge win for him yep
well there you go we have a one-game
lead we have speed chess hype the hype
is real this is this is exciting the
finals is going to come down to the wire
at this point that seems where we're
headed a car Nakamura fending off what
could have been the first three-game
lead in the match and then and then you
start talking whoa right I don't know
why I said whoa but that's what you
start saying after three game leads
happen yeah and I'm still I'm saying a
little bit of whoa because I don't like
it he keeps coming back to this video we
talked about the Italian we said that
was he's been doing very well with it
from the white side he's gonna go rookie
two here
f1 it goes away from his favorite rookie
- I guess he was worried about some
sacrifices in the gf3 square I was like
what am i doing like yeah I don't like
what I'm thinking about okay so now he's
gonna have to deal with the same type of
space advantage that so has been getting
consistently this Italian and in a bad
pawn structure yeah and and again I mean
I know Carl hasn't liked some of his
calculation and things but again from a
match strategy we know he looked at the
Italian for LaVon maybe he felt like
that was the easy one to roll out
against Wesley so but it is not working
here maybe he's just if I were him I
switch this Sicilian I would switch of
the Sicilian I would I've pretty much he
puts a carrot on sometimes yeah I
wouldn't put the carrot Khan against
Wesley he's even played a Pierce at
times yeah but those type of positions
against a grater get especially playing
lower rated players but you have more
experience and I mean you don't want to
take on a less than the best opening
against a 2800 player like Wesley so but
I just think at this point even if you
became prepared to play the Italian it's
not working right and it's why I'm
Sicilian in particular because I think
there's other openings you mentioned are
perfectly playable openings of course
yeah with a space issue I think well
that's Picard is really struggling with
is when he's not getting enough space in
his position
yeah he's ending up not finding the best
plans and then was he's punishing him
and now he's doing a good job in this
particular game because he's coming on
yeah he's maneuvered his way out of what
was a bad start for black and now here
comes 95 these are the positions acara
wants right space on the Kings side so
if Queen g6 we could actually see a
repetition here night h4 Queen f6 Knight
back to f3 and then Agora would take
that I think take that with a chance to
move back to playing with the white
pieces I think that's where we're headed
yeah because he's okay he went Knight d4
which I'm not positive okay actually
that makes sense a bishop takes d4 pawn
takes d4 the knight Black Knight is
coming to the f4 square soon though it
still is looking promising here yep so
Bishop yeah this is this is where Hikaru
can do well I mean look at the F file
just think is was he gonna just move his
Knight away but that look too passive
how you said you can't stop 94 from
coming yeah no this is the kind of
Italian I think a karo envisioned when
he said I'm gonna take on these
positions
lack yeah and this is just the first
time he's gotten it so I cool but I just
take it get a car wants it mate hey Cara
wanna attack me g6 nice move hey Cara
want King rook takes f3 is threatened
hey Cara want King rook takes if there's
a hanging piece as well in addition to
the arrows you drew I want you to draw
more yes so you draw there I'll play it
all night long Lionel Richie still
haven't drawn there I know you're
Freddie bro takes a three but Zoe's not
gonna allow that but this is the plan
that's concrete Robert I think winning a
free piece is the most concrete plan
today I will show Roberts line if Wes if
karo if Wesley plays this move I will
just show the line but as I said not
gonna happen and here comes my move
Knight f4 thank you okay
now you can't take h3 right away which
would undef' end the night because of
the discovery on the Queen but maybe
maybe hey Carlo should have played the
move you said just take e5 when it was
there because now things were getting a
little shaky oh I'm surprised he did
take you five in that moment he just did
I thought he was taking on d3 that pawn
was hanging from the point now everyone
is if the knight comes back we'll get
the tactic I wanted before you take and
you undermine the defense of the f3
Knight and with it probably quickly win
the game so Wesley has to defend that I
don't need five but not allow those
types of tactics do you play the other
rook to e1 92 oh nice we have a text
here good night g4 to avoid this yeah
but then it girl gobbles d3 so it's
Queen d7 30e six d4 piece f2 these are
all hanging pollen b7 I mean everything
it's all it's all hanging all right so
the car gets f2 first but I wonder if
Wesley helped himself a lot by being
able to grab one with check and defend
she for yeah I would have taken on the
e6 there with check I thought he would
but now he Caro has a swishing sook
we need five and he finds it at guards
e6 and Brooke a do you want is just but
there would be two but then I take take
Quinn d4 okay black oh look at you look
at my baby girl waking up over here next
to me but uh calculating now well that's
what we just got butts up a pawn still
good for black though I agree with you
but still you know if the Queen's get
trainee you're only a pawn down it could
have some chance the hope but the
problem is the King safety the Pawnee
six actually really helps blacks King
wears whites King they will never find
true safety here yeah this is looking
very nice for a car and be a great
comeback for him considering where we
just saw him two games ago your last
game when he was down two and looked
like he was on his way to losing a third
no but if a car wins this again he will
have stopped the bleeding with vengeance
right pretty sure that's Bruce Willis is
next Brooke a flinch rook takes before
if you take a six we have Queen e5 check
up here what you want oh nice
and Brooke before LuAnn a sex boom boom
boom boom hikaru sees it hey Cara want
it okay Wesley doesn't allow it Queen c3
but now the rook can come to the second
rank and we're hitting the the g2 pond
okay okay also good good cuz you're
threatening rook f1 yeah try to trade
pieces because he's up to pawns here
okay but he's also still guarding a6 so
you can't even take it cuz we'll take on
g2 first right so hey Carl can played
with like a five right
maybe that's the movie five i dint Akane
six but then I take G to take oh you
have 24 at the end of Queen she's six
you take E 5 we didn't even see you were
talking about it was I was highlighting
that it was there when I didn't see it
was so direct g6 in Queen g7 there is no
perpetual only Zuul
that's a Ghostbusters keymaster
reference you're welcome thank you okay
the king will just go up to have five
and this was a slightly awkward approach
from black I feel like the line I was
saying with g6 and the Queen comes all
the way back around was also enough for
Hikaru but but okay this should win and
Wesley also down to 19 seconds we're
kind of seeing the first signs of Hikaru
being the faster one in these in these
near the equal position time scrambles
so that's dangerous if you're a so guy
look at that maneuver he's such a beast
calculating these bullet games
Erik Hansen just like had like a
flashback panic attack watching that
game right that's how I feel like the
amount of times I've seen him beat the
chest for all is in positions like that
it's not that has nothing against them I
mean they adopt me on a regular basis
but I've been on issues again
take our many many many times that was
that was bananas how fast he calculated
that let's remind everybody of the daily
question if you could change one thing
about the SCC format what would it be
we're asking that in all earnest cuz we
love you we appreciate you thanks for
being here watching and if you enjoy the
format we've already got opinions on
bringing Fischer random back which again
Fischer random is the same thing as
chess960 there was some confusion there
that's just a branding mistake by
whoever did that'll long ago
it's called 960 because there are 960
possible positions when you when you do
the the power of eight there and flip
everything around on the back rank but
Fischer random because Bobby Fischer
pretty much invented it anyway so that's
a quick history lesson as to why it's
Fischer random versus 960 get involved
and let us know if you have any other
ideas that you would like to see
implemented for the SEC right now Wesley
so wants to implement some new ideas can
I can I give one yeah it's not repeating
the same openings when they're not
working for you
oh wait that's that's that advice
players yeah that's not a format thing
that's your coaching advice kicking in
yeah teaching moment by Bobby has
brought to you I mean the cars position
is bad again with the white pieces just
black has more space pawn d3 is gonna be
a target here yep
so Bishop f5 I guess you can just take
on d3 now okay if you take on d3 there's
gonna be some queenside counter chances
the car so maybe I spoke quick second
too soon yeah Wesley
kind of skeptical if I write a plan here
I think he likes his position but that
facials question I think he just doesn't
exactly know the right plan he wants he
said he knows he likes the orange juice
though try to go b6 at some point does
it keep his King safer it sounds weird
right you're keeping your king safe with
my place by moving a pawn around it but
in this case b7 is such a target you
want to get it off that spot there move
it from b7 so you don't worry about yeah
and he agrees with you and the problem
for white as was you can't go c5 because
your knight on d5 is hanging so you
figure out how to handle both yeah you
want to pry open things but keep your
night on that dominant square and you
may not be able to have both so maybe
he's calculating ideas where he comes
back and then play c5
Wesley has already achieved the counter
play with E for that black wants in this
line and now you can even move your
night away from c6 oh I was gonna say
you could take it by 95 or Bishop e6
them coming after the d3 pawn turning g5
at some point Elgin I can come to d4 d5
weird direction this game is headed I
feel like a carros counter plays just
being kicked back and Wesley's position
just remains very clear very direct as
far as the weakness you're gonna attack
not sure what Hikaru
was thinking there with the queenside
played maybe he can still play c5 and
tried to sacrifice his pawn go for an
opposite colored Bishop ending that way
give drawing chances but he's definitely
just much worse here Leslie playing
quickly and relaxed lifting up the arm
right whoa dude he just missed queen g4
it instead of King to b7 was that
possible I guess you could take any five
first my idea was to put Knight f3 check
and you're not a force hanging yeah but
there might in term is oh yeah now hey
Carl does see that idea coming no he
plays h3 to kind of stop that look at
that
yeah the d3 points falling Carl probably
thought he could take here but his pawn
takes back right I think he's gonna go
for a line like this and just accept
that he's worse in this major piece
ending and try to hold that's actually
probably the smartest way to handle this
it's still great black yeah you see you
have this idea there's some separated
pawns that blacks better but that looks
like may be your best option
this is happening so yeah he takes just
no 92 yeah yeah so he goes for that line
there we go
well the Queen takes g5 is not a threat
here because of HA uh h5 is a black well
key thing guards it anyway and I think a
Carl will play Brooke e3 like I was
saying earlier and then you can try to
you know get surgical up in this and
maybe slowly into your weight of targets
but the black has the majority
rook d6 I would play for black
protecting that right away instead of
rookie 3 yeah I think either waiver up
d6 is gonna be the response and out okay
rook see one's a good move if rook c6
you takin black can't protect both a
five and age six at the same time yeah
good point if you take with the
you guard aged 655 if you take with the
king you guard e5 but not aged six story
of my life let's see I don't want to go
rook d7 back but I was defending six
Falls yeah Ricardo has found his way to
kind of create some counter play here
despite the dubious opening and and it's
nice that he took that 95 approach so
he's he's holding five but then what you
have to carry a queen c1 Queen a four
check it probably doesn't actually lead
to a win he aim for black yeah cuz you
always have to consider what happens if
I start trading some pieces yep
I'll actually like what was he's doing
yeah he's trying to just use the
majority on the Queen side but you
Carmen could play f4 and say look I know
I'm still drawing it best in fact he
goes for it and I think this is the
right practical approach because
sometimes people are too hesitant to
open their king and queen endings
because obviously you give bunch of
checks but the point is something when
you're worse you just have to go for
lines like this I think because you're
accepting that your best result is a
draw but if Wesley doesn't take it here
comes the f1 right and I think that's a
that's actually a really inadvertently
instructive moment there for everyone
when you look at them look at the
evaluation I think white is actually
gonna have much better chances to draw
and black may have to bail out with a
perpetual because that F pawn is so fast
also the Queen on e5 is just just a
beast in the center and again it's just
sometimes people lose those n games
because they're too hesitant to open
their own King but learn from Hikaru
trying I've been trying my whole life
you know what I'm right there with you
buddy
I think your car was saved it yeah he
did so now like we said if Wesley
doesn't take the draw you may lose right
and that's one of those things that is
just really instructive there from how
Hikaru played out for that's uh that's a
take away put in your pocket all right
it's good for later it's funny that you
take the draw because we didn't even
know that draw was offered you said that
yeah I didn't it was a game drama mutual
agreement I've just been you know I I
laid off the coffee today my brain is
doing better without the coffee is it it
is let's try to you this Roy here is
water before like I want whatever
Danny's drinking its water I promise you
yeah relax
top quality h2o as it
nothing but some high-quality h2o Bobby
Boucher okay we're back to brookie -
instead of rack f1 will this decision
buy a car to break the pauses much
better for a car than the last one we
saw though with a d5 brake already
happening but now that Queen b3 happens
they defend d5 and f3 at the same time
you like me
me likey car has to prove he can get
back this pawn yep
I'm not sure he's getting it back yeah
Wesley's just gonna hold on to it the
bishop will probably back up to d7
because I don't think taking makes any
sense that you can ask the question
after Bishop whoa he's gonna overload
the Queen first cuz if she leaves the
third-ranked now I will trade right but
he should be sitting on 95 ah you're
right gosh that would be so dominant in
fact that's why he had to do it the cart
gonna say you either take on double
pawns or you give me back my deep on I
would take takes the double pawns to
hold on to it now the question is I go
Bishop f4 encouraging black to take
enough for ya because my structure yeah
and I'll plant my work on e5 next but
I'm worried about the Queen coming to be
fool what do you play
g4 hmm I can use my g4 emote for the
first time there's that I'm coming I'm
fighting you so 6x8 car is their
favorite okay now there's a there's a
big problem my favorite emo spot there
you go Oh glad I got to use that today
this rook F 1 there's Knight f6 somehow
yeah and no but that kind of a key for
no I was the D for fonts hanging with
check no but you can't do it but oh you
get the bishop duh I'm wrong I'm sorry
and there's no yeah okay so that was the
tactic but I mean before also going
after the d4 pawn through the bishop
perhaps yeah and the analysis that we're
doing okay Chloe didn't happen but oh
yeah sorry I'm highlighting else's board
but all right well we're watching the
live game here the important to note
that ninety five is kind of stuck there
for a little bit yeah we were just
highlight
this idea but you didn't miss anything
don't worry a tree but the night's stuck
because sometimes if you try movin it
the g6 night is hanging yes of the pin
very nice I like that move rook F - sort
of an obvious move but a strong one also
white play h4 h5 to keep bed night away
from g6 we're trying to launch an attack
and the one thing we got to observe
about how Wesley has rebounded here is
he's not down on time nearly like he was
of that move - you see - because after
b5 for Bishop d3 with me that would be a
full full risk I don't like that move
takes a 4 is gonna allow Queen d4 check
and then and then b5 or b5 right away
it's a fork oh hey Carl feeling it he
just dumped one during the piece Wesley
just grabbed his mouth oh my gosh talk
about the opposite reaction you're
hoping for Wesley's gonna try to get
some counter play but he just
miscalculated and blundered that Bishop
on she finds the Queen III check is a
good move because you wanted rookies g7
is a threat yep
so you can't take on f7 right now cuz
rook takes f7 Queen takes f7 check was
he is very upset I mean you saw him grab
his mouth there yeah you moved the
knight first it looks like that's the
key you can hit G to guard qi7
okay that's what I thought a car would
do but you did this so he could take on
f7 ah that makes sense yeah now you're
guarding everything take f7 and put the
Clin here and that still so clear that
was that was just totally just my honest
yeah that was not a good decision he
just hung us he's gone that's why we
hope we bought it he's like what am i
doing well first of all I think my
knight h4 was was much better to start
right well the same thing happens right
you trade rooks in f8 yeah and then what
and then you go Quinn a check and take
on c6 so you're gonna fade again ah okay
you guard g2 at the other line okay so
maybe this position was never as as
super simple as you thought so he's
gonna have to prove himself I think a
car was still very good winning chances
here
Queen and Knight are so tricky but
definitely much better for so than it
could have been given that he has
drawing chances with the open King here
it's actually one of the positions you
were just saying before if you press too
much you could actually backfire Luis
yeah
the knight could actually lose because
if when white takes on c6 then white
will take on b5 and I have three pawns
for the night
yeah and then black may have to bail out
with some sort of draw right yep so
that's what looks likely at this point
yeah if he's bailing out with the draw
he's definitely just acknowledging his
frustration with how he handled that but
something tells me he's still gonna try
for a win just wait I don't know I don't
know but is it for brown or several now
oh no that was fourteen again it's the
look over the shoulder that says he's
thinking about the past sad again I've
cataloged these they are very well known
when the past bog you down like that
past bugs you down by that right got a
move on
yep yesterday's history tomorrow a
mystery today okay what else is a gift
is all of you following us whether
you're with us on Twitch twenty thousand
of you just calm TV or on Twitter
here's some answers to our a daily
question I'd like to see you bring back
the +2 increments that a +1 interesting
that's moving the other way some of the
requests to make it faster you get
better games less Flags it's true it's
true
okay I'd like to see more players
involved in the competition that's gonna
happen because we're gonna have more
qualifiers for some of the younger
juniors we're gonna I don't know that
the main event itself is ever gonna be
more than 16 but as far as the
opportunities for qualification to get
there I think we do have a lot of
excitement about that now this is a line
that we've seen both these players go
for some Wesley btik are within this
line at the US Championship and the
words deceitful cutting cut okay white
side of this opening yeah so this is
Hikaru playing something too Wesley's
played trying to maybe beat him with his
own medicine and well speak of beating
with his own medicine was he just pulled
off a car look number yeah looked know
that number seven is [__] okay theory
number seven is opening how about the
looks inside okay that's 11 okay that's
yeah and was he was doing that before he
have no but that was it was early enough
to dues remembering theory okay gotcha
amateurs over here I've tried to turn to
be be in my own head Caro
hey Carl what catalogue game I mean
sorry no I loved it I know but seriously
we were both right to remember the
sinful couples that this year that was
2016 16 2016 time flies
Wow what you're having fun we're
commenting together we're just thank you
anyway but yeah this is interesting and
both sides sort of primed here this is
this is the these guys like no this is a
close match somebody in the chat was
just saying come back for Wesley if you
look at the scoreboard still even right
there is no comeback and needed for
either player right now both sides
trying to get their first lead these are
two heavyweight fighters going at it and
we only have ten minutes left here where
we get into the bullet all the the
anticipation I'm wondering will be over
and we'll see how Wesley can hold in the
fastest segment yeah this position is
like the ugliest pawn structure I think
in any writing in chess but there are
some themes lack has oh yeah go ahead
you have you wish of East 7 for example
yep there's sometimes you go rook d5 and
sacrifice yes in fact that's exactly
what Wesley did when he beated karo in
this thing fill Cup that year not this
exact position but it was the same type
of thing regarded that you fix your
structure and and you've got all kinds
of opportunities for counter play so a
carro taking a think here takes the c6
pawn okay but you still have the
exchange sack idea in a lot of positions
because the C pawn is so strong and
because the activity of these pieces
kind of makes up for the sack exchange
sack so again you can look up that game
the Wesley so versus a card and I'll
come more a game there and that was a
really nice game and now f3 okay that I
just played for but white is down upon
that C pawn as you mentioned as a passed
pawn yeah Brooke could be once coming oh
very nice and now now actually black is
getting the counter play you want in
this line yeah you for didn't come in
time yeah why does one move too short
from preventing this idea and you your
Bishop on a3 has to stay there you like
Bishop c1 try not to trade the rooks
Queen c5 check wins that Bishop was
oopsie
and that's the downside playing with f3
you
of the diagonal king can become a bit
vulnerable but if you take on be one
rook takes to be one Queen be one
similar idea of your King F to this
Queen b6 checks you gotta watch out for
this I was just play schemes you - but
now a2 is gonna fall right and after HC
falls e - is hanging yeah
ro has something to figure out here and
he's played Bishop b2 very quickly so
maybe he feels he can hold the obstacle
of Bishop ending and I actually think
Leslie miss an opportunity from or
instead of playing Queen takes a - but
we can that's a story for another day
but I think he actually could have got
more out of the press we on board
because the King on g2 became vulnerable
break now here two pawns actually
practice of two pawns the car was
showing us the scowl which you know is
understandable he knows he has his work
cut out for him but black has other
things to figure out this Bishop lacks
clear plans this Bishop is a beast right
no darks for a counterpart for black and
whites King gets active much more
quickly so I think black is better but
but Wesley knows this is not a super
easy kind of hanging - what do you want
bishop see it's a go Bishop d7 I don't
know you stop that Oh Ally that hurts
and her car is looking car was like wow
this is dumb
yeah but now Bishop d7 happens anyway no
matter what yeah and you should be seven
Bishop f6 politics of six ocean baby
take that - interesting that's not the
worst transition for white if you can
keep these two points backwards 98 I got
you five probably be five keeps the
knight from reaching those Desirables
and daehak-ro sees that this is still
weird again I think Wesley's favorite
here and he may jump back to elite
before we head into bullet but f6 f6 f4
yeah but it but it but it's not that
easy for black but the problem for wise
the King can't run too far because in
Black Will O king g6 so like take me
five look at you using both sides of the
board you just passed my chest
f+ he decided okay he's no king g7 pawn
c6 that's his plan now okay but the King
gets to c5 just in time g5 oh no you
know g4 and lucky for your knight is
never free look at that
look at that beast that's that that's a
donkey again I want to break free from
the chance
you wish you could so go h5 to start
with I guess but then your h3 still the
dog days are just beginning for that
night yeah look at that
g4 HD the night has nowhere to go that's
a hemmed-in pony
I think it's draw yeah the karo plays
for a win he loses because black gets
seasick so if you're wondering why
doesn't a car go get the pawn but then
black would get c6
what an interesting safe there look at
this battle this is like Hikaru was
better last game push push push barely
you know didn't come up yep right and
then and then soz better in that game
but Hikaru holds on and we have nothing
but a gridlock baby yeah I'm not trying
to use with a G thing gridlock I'm
surprised that just happened because I
really thought was he was gonna win that
one easily and he went 98 which I
suggested and immediately regretted that
right he 5 amazing how quickly the night
got trapped there yeah yeah I think what
was his big mistake was he brought the
king over the Queen side which is so
natural yep but if kept the Queen on the
king assumed the king on the King side
who we talked about decoys right the
palms and the Queen said we're decoys so
yep yeah yeah well this is very likely
gonna be our last game here in 2-3
minute portion assuming that those five
minutes disappear before someone
blunders and then we want to bullet and
then people are already thinking hey
what if this whole thing remains tied
after bullet well we have over time that
that immediately ensues if we want to
remind everybody the format we can but
it's a little tricky but because we
might actually have a tie here maybe
it's useful to tell you what happens if
the speech Chess Championship goes into
tiebreakers we have actually I don't
even know can we bring back the format
image really really quickly because I
actually need to remember okay if the
match is tied it's a one plus one game a
tiebreaker for additional 1+1 games is
played so they play four games that's
actually new this year this is what
happens when Pete makes the rules and
not me anyway just kidding Pete love you
buddy and if the match is still tied
after that mini match we have a single
Armageddon game white getting 5 minutes
of black ending 3 minutes so all right
back to the chess here but I actually
needed to remember because I was asked a
question just now by our producer in my
ear and I actually didn't know the
answer did you know that we had 4
one plus one games no could I leave that
stuff up to you apparently I left that
stuff up to Pete and we've got I think
Pete did that because he wants more
chess he's a big big chess fan that guy
yeah figure I think in the past the way
it worked was if we went to overtime
it was just whoever won I was 94 yeah
pawn takes Evo pawn takes c4 ok well the
night of 6 is hanging but the Queen on
d2 is now hanging as well with the open
file so Queen needs to figure out where
to go don't want to go to c3 excels in
95 with it big tempo very queen see I
love that you couldn't finish your set
and quickly - that was a good one I
don't know there's a lot of squares you
went to see one ultimately okay I'll
take it now the knight does have to move
indeed it does I actually like this for
black I feel like the activities coming
and now there's a little trick here
watch out for bishop takes h3o so well
that technique Oh Stacey okay now you
gotta take with the rook after trading
or the Queen any piece that guards f3
you wanna take with the Queen to see
forward I guess I liked it Carter too
soon because I thought that bishop pair
would get nasty over here but now that I
know that the smoke is cleared I look at
this e5 pawn and I like it
for what yeah you're a pawn right but so
the bishops are very good pieces of
course it's Queen a for coming here just
to pin the rook down hit the c4 pawn but
I guess if the Queen afore this mean to
be one that's one of whites main ideas
here is if Queen b1 happens and g6 and
b7 are under attack if I quit me one
here isn't certainly an option because
you would love to remove that g6 sponsor
and I can go into h5 or f5 oh yeah board
as well okay Leslie finds another way to
get a bow cuz if Queen 64 of rooks III
is coming that's a piece oh it's not
yeah but I'm just claiming my rook on
the seventh rank is definitely worth the
exchange - I don't know oh hey Carl tree
okay so he's gonna be five only move
yeah save the piece Save Ferris
Ferris Bueller no Save Ferris no hey car
doesn't think it's the only move
he thinks that Bishop d3 or Bishop d5
are also possible interesting okay he
goes with it but that's what he was
calculating I think because a fourth
threads to undermine that Bishop at the
same time I don't want to give any meat
Oh a4 for white yeah a four for white I
just want to give a passed pawn so
easily that's out of the board yep
Bishop takes e5 is not hanging here okay
it is he's a transpose until he pawned
down but likely drawn again Knight takes
e5 rook T 294 BC for Brooksie force all
this happening you take on a - he's go
rook c6 c7 put poise you put the rook
behind the pawn yep
and the question is will will hick ro
try to push on or if they take a quick
draw we might actually get one more
3-minute game the car would be very
smart to purchase on until the time yeah
I think so and Hikaru is the most
experienced player in the format and I
think he's aware of the situation so if
he if he does take the draw quickly it's
because he wants another 3-minute game I
bet Hakkar was aware of just how much
time is left
yeah he can take himself down to 30
seconds and then I just offered room but
if he doesn't
although actually if you think about he
has white in the next game
and that's true maybe he wants one more
white I mean it at this point it's the
debate does he Carra one bullet does
acara want another chance to get a win
with the white pieces now he's he's
going aggressive for this opportunity
once the point is once the King gets too
close now you start checking from behind
right okay you could have checked last
move but even this is just fine
you wait and so this will be instructive
for the for the members here because
okay officially we have indeed crossed
into the realm of one-minute chess is
around the corner so don't go anywhere
this is a deadlock match we couldn't
have asked for more here at the speeches
championship finals I think this game is
gonna end up in a draw so don't look at
that engine bar on the left and let me
just show everybody the analysis it's
this King touches here okay so let's say
the King touches as soon as it's
guarding the pawn what happens is white
gives check from behind and then goes
right back and so if you're looking at
the analysis and wondering
is this a draw the point is the king can
never touch the pawn without getting
checked and if you can't ever protect
the pawn then your can never move
because then the pawn hangs straight up
yeah so this is a this is just an
endgame you just have to know in the
back of your head is a strong chess
player that if you get the rooks stuck
here with the pawn without some other
weaknesses on this side of the board you
just can never win because the King
makes the long journey gets checked away
and we rinse and repeat like shampoo
again
these guys both sporting very good sets
of hair no dandruff so far in this feat
Chess Championship love delivering the
most serious information of all I'm also
gonna love commentating on the bullet
portion because we're locked at 10:00
let's go do 10 games a piece this is
exciting it's hype chess Brasi that's
your heart out okay let's do it we're
gonna be back in just a few moments
don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
and since we are tied here heading into
the bullet portion of the speed Chess
Championship final
gonna remind everybody what happens if
the match is tied if the last one one
bullet game is not enough for us to have
a clear winner there will be four
additional 1/1 games played a little
mini match kind of just like the World
Chess Championship rapid format meaning
first two two and a half points is gonna
win and if the match is still tied after
that we will have an Armageddon game so
maybe Pete just aligned himself with the
world chess championship rule so he gets
format credit let's remind everybody of
course of what the daily question was
and a couple of the great tweets we had
I hear we had one that in football they
have a miked up where they play audio
clips from the players after big plays
that is actually a very intuitive
comment and I could tell you that
something we're working on for future
events we might do at the for like the
live finals when we when we hold kind of
our eSport events that may be something
we have already discussed or not I
obviously just said it was so good job
Danny spoiler alert you suck okay moving
on I'd like the speeches to become the
World Chess Championship format thank
you that's about as good of a comment
you can have if you are wondering what
these tweets are about the daily
question was asking directly what would
you change about the speech s
championship format if you could you
have a last chance to get involved the
best answers get Diamond memberships
we're already gonna give away a few
Diamond memberships to some of the great
comments we've had so if you have won
any comments you want to give in the
last half hour this is your chance this
is the chance for both these guys to
take home big prizes we got five grand
on the line through the winter then an
additional five grand
based on win percentage $10,000 alone
just for this three-hour match no more
talking buy us these guys are ready
ready for this
what do you say no more talking about us
I've been silent just so I can keep my
voice for ya I'm gonna be relying on it
so take it away part well here we go we
see a car go off for the B three again
and he plays in the center you can give
oftentimes give oh ninety two so instead
of trading queens
maybe pre moved I think you're just
pre-boot blunder
yeah thanks first free move blunder of
the day yep just you just you just that
was not the move you were supposed to
play not at all b6 I don't like that
move oh six was coming but c6 Bishop
before check through them
oh okay or just nicely five and to
corral that policy six okay saying that
you know you haven't developed enough to
keep it but hey Cara has other ideas
yeah of course played positions like
this before and I know okay yeah thanks
Captain Obvious but no it's really
important because he's so familiar with
the common tactics and these b3 systems
it's why he goes back to a time and time
again in his bullet games yep and
because even if yeah I think black is
fine here right you ready I mean
Wesley's fine but again Hikaru is just
so familiar with this he likes it in
fact I like was he's position because
the light squares we keep talking with
us when you lose that light square
bishop oh look back bishop basics check
coming okay but you're lucky don't lose
a piece just rip d2 isn't there's an
item b3 covering it
yeah after Bishop d6 were that night
going if you go to c4 I think you can't
go to c4 I just take it I guess whatever
see it first I guess you know I I think
Wesley did find it opening I again I'm
just not as sold that Hikaru isn't right
where he wants to be especially in
Bullitt now the time has been impressive
so far that's what I'm looking at will
Wesley hang with Hikaru as as we have
less time here to start each game well
so far so far he is but I'd love the
potential of the C pawn right yeah I
completely agree now that C pawn is
really advanced it's only a couple moves
before you a c7 rookie one and try yeah
punch that pawn through okay but there's
some clear counter play for black King G
up threes nevermind that h5 check at
some point but I guess you are holding
on just in time Wow good walking the
King up
yeah because of g6 your g4 yeah I was
just about to say the chief for move is
coming and maybe I get another chance
for my emote nope don't get it well this
is a good decision by was a very good
practical decision saying if your king
takes on h5 I take the bishop
so now rook takes g2 but the Knights
hang you know King eh I've work takes c6
and so you got just getting mated you
have two pawns and the a two point is
also hanging in many lines here so but a
car was gonna take the money and run
he's saying I'm up a piece and I'm gonna
cheat prove it but you can't go King h3
can just 600 would that not be delicious
so rook c2 year blunders Bishop f6 check
so let's say what do I have to throw in
here okay giving up f6 King after Bishop
takes f6 as well time though now you can
play e5 and even cut
the rock I thought that's what he would
do but this also works and again
does it work though take take see to you
to go bishop somewhere I guess we didn't
even have to know the bishop is
perfectly placed the king can come back
and win the pawn I think White's just
yeah the bishop is there he maybe was
showing even around that bishop getting
in the game but look at this defense but
I still think a five is the best move
right there by Hikaru and then bring the
King back but he didn't go for it oh
look at that if you take on a through
Brooks III check was available but hey
Carlos sees it sees all the rook is
overloaded that's the big problem there
rookie six he's winning the piece he
freaks out cuz he missed he five okay oh
but he's still winning in the king the
king upon a king would be yes that's
what I was saying but I think he's still
better in the rook ending yeah he is and
he's got a huge time advantage yeah
seconds you're coming in hand that was
very resourceful by Wesley though you
could see the get I haven't we ever seen
him Carl gasp and bring his fingers to
his lips that we have six that was brand
new Hikaru seven you have to keep make
sure you don't give it a five is coming
if you want though well we talked about
it right in the Carlsen car wanna match
yeah well you the two on one is much
hard to win but if they're it's two on
one with the pawns are separate yeah
easy flip on your easy job with this
pawn here not easy to do if you put the
Jeep on on H five then it's completely
winning on this yeah so look at Wesley
pay Presley's yeah still just defending
super resourcefully here with no time on
the clock six seconds I'm very impressed
by Wesley here he's clearly putting up a
big fight but his times ticking down
it's gonna be hard to continue to hold
for sure YUM hey Carl finally Oh only
one second he barely made a move in time
look at move king e5 can't move because
nobody history of six pack six you can
play e5 but if I just take it and my
Brooks king and rook are perfectly plays
you to hold f4 you're right
so now can you believe I have to bring
the King back 0.9 seconds one point nine
Wesley barely holding Hikaru he's gonna
work this time scramble attack I'm very
proud of him home rook g1 he could have
taken on g2 I think it now he's got the
King gauge five though oh I thought
that's what he wanted takes almost put
ourselves on being net taking a four
I always got g4 and you know King for
kh3 yeah occasionally can't f3 yeah he
would have taken it oh oh oh you forgot
no it's a losing endgame if you go g4 I
just take on g4 and
still winning oh my gosh Wow Wow
a car barely gets that one through there
he car was like still like he's still
questioning what just happened like the
rest of us well I wasn't winning and it
wasn't winning at him so Wesley should
have traded rooks he should not have
yeah yeah I suggested he did it and well
my bad what happens when you listen to
Robert yeah even though he can't hear me
Wow no but I I was with you I thought it
was a draw as well but the King
shoulders on the outside let's keep the
main live board up let's go back to the
mini analysis board and I'm gonna show
that okay I'm gonna try to even though
it's bullet try to keep my focus yeah
you look at the main game and I'm gonna
pull this up and just show why it was
resigns for everybody just keep your eye
on the mini analysis port if you're
interested in learning king upon innings
g4 after cakes the King has to choose
and the point is if the King takes this
one I'm shouldering on the outside and
in these end games I get here just in
time to have opposition if the same
thing happens with the Jeep on I get to
the outside of the pawn and we both
thought it was a draw but the point is
once your King gets past the counterpart
then it's just gonna walk the dog all
the way up the board and protect it
every square of the way and and that
would happen in either one of these
variations where the King gets here and
shoulder actually here it doesn't matter
because black is wherever you go I get
opposition and I shoulder you and again
now I just walk the dog up the board
with my king guarding every square so
that's a very very quick example we'll
go back to the live game but super
instructive stuff and shocking there to
see you Carlos Steele before the first
bullet game yeah he really did steal
that one Wesley look at it he's 45
seconds of a great position look at this
backwards c6 pawn I'm throwing to play a
takes d5 and you take back on d5 with
the pawn and you lose the beef iPod all
the Saqqara wants a horrible doesn't
work Kokoro once mate doesn't work the
night two nights are there protect me h2
square so he's desperate there c6 still
hanging queenie 6 can always trade the
queen's the bishop on c7 looks good but
it's attacking nothing it's air can't
get a battery so love it queen 66 looks
like a free pawn but I guess 95 take the
ladies off the board that's also good
for white I think it's a wise choice
because the knight was kicked off the f3
score Queen takes have to check comes
and the rook on the second rank is very
valuable there so now you can probably
get away with taking c6 and he does
because Knight blocks the
you can't even you to go for this
because now that I'm up to I'll just go
right back in trade Queens in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if we see that
Wesley plays more aggressively but okay
he's just whipping every pawn but he's
gobbling them now you even got no you
don't because trade and Bishop takes up
to in the end that he made
honestly despite the fact that he's up a
lot more that organ I don't think he's
gonna be happy with every reddit I've
worked up to work a seven I guess Nova
then overlooking one and then I have to
trickiness I'd have to first and only
once Knight takes h3 to the tactics are
bananas sleeve abortive just Bishop e8
9595 he holds on over there Bishop takes
e5 93 yeah but now here comes a knight
takes h3 or Bishop g3 again I think
Wesley should have just been happy with
the second pawn and played Queen e6 and
now he's rookie odo rookie three goes be
sure to check so don't blender like me
look at that just ignoring the fact that
his rooks under it's a crook III now
yeah very nice I'm gonna force the
winning end game and this exactly [__]
my last game yeah where you have the
what now it doesn't matter but but you
have the two pawns to pawn is connected
right here comes c4 car was gonna do his
last-ditch effort to create outside
passer b5 as counter play with chief or
maybe even h4 he'll play don't even know
he doesn't but okay should be just be
winning for white with accurate moves
here Wesley has to okay guard the g2
Square there will no be no Queen and now
I've got two passers I don't love
exactly how he's played this because
Knight is tied down outside the board
don't want that Oh actually yeah now all
the sudden the bishop is dominating the
night yep and this is this is far from
ideal what the knight back she's
calculating whether he can get away with
Knight of three but he can't Wow was
miss opportunities Hikaru feeling lucky
with that one he just escaped
literally escaped by the by the many
hairs on his chin today maybe that's why
you grow a beard
increase your chances to escape by the
hairs on your chinny chin chin that was
that was an amazing save and that may be
why he ultimately goes on to win if he
could hold the games where he's worse
right hey Carl we know is super
dangerous he's back to his be three
systems and objectively Rob and I are
not disagreeing of we like black
objectively in a lot of these
ditions but Hikaru knows what he's doing
in these lines and very important he's
doing it quickly yeah right well you
only have one minute for the whole game
you have to move we're gonna look at her
cards more time and he started with yep
whoa taking a quick breath here wowzers
wowzers well she's gonna go knight c6
there it is yeah now White's getting the
bishop Aaron very happily gonna be gonna
be playing the endgame it's we've had
these positions were white held and he
and black had the bishop here on the
light squares here your White's got a
nice position with the night here you
can can you play Knight takes no he
can't do that
protecting I was thinking about this 97
exactly Wow
King f8 9 c8 rook c8 and okay it's a new
bishops but he is gonna get the bishop
here the Brook comes to c1 and this is
this is this is uh okay but II four
squares we had ninety four check just
ninety four check now take off so you
wanna play Knight c3 at the end oh my
gosh Eliseo so Dora look at your tactics
flying out yep somebody somebody's uh
calculating here nicely three hits the
bishop if de to pawn so King J you have
to wow Bishop to d3 a two-point angel as
well Kokoro has let this one slip
despite is he losing a two next i guess
not no a 2-bit should be one chops
tonight so he the night took the the
bishop would trap the night so if you're
Wesley do just try to offer a draw and
say I think there's still plenty enough
time in the match you don't necessarily
have to the one game lead for her karo
19 minutes left but the reason Roberts
said that everyone is from a match
strategy perspective again the speeches
championship is different because Wesley
also only has 19 minutes left right in
if you remain down a game well you've
run out of time wait a second there goes
the a pawn but Hikaru is gonna keep his
Bishop here yeah it's stuck I'd this is
close though weather fish before they
pick in b3 King c4 I try to get an e5 at
some point it's gaining some ground yeah
he's making progress he's in first
County for maybe a really instructive
endgame ahead of us but happens again
we'll analyze it on the small board if
it's something that we feel we can play
24 or was he can you for it yeah and
then now she five any fiber boat IV five
he's making breakthroughs wow I spoke
taken
I don't know if the car was gonna hold
this big enough for Oh what-what Oh
bishop xe5 he's no king see for Bishop
d6 a5 and pushed that pawn
where's Yasser push him baby Wow and he
Carlos sees it and agrees with it so
much so that he doesn't even take that
free point now I just gave up the pawn
what's he doing there okay he wanted to
gift a key ones go to g5 so trying to
come out always trying to keep the
structure this is amazing yeah very and
look at the analysis board the point is
if white takes here and any position
black will get g5 and now have the extra
pass pawn that he needs and I'm Scott
Bishop endings it's not how many pawns
you have it's who who has the ability to
actually make progress and get a queen
and I've seen you too
if king g v g5 amelia he has f4 yeah but
chief I will take take and then after f4
he'll go
Bishop b6 I guess okay the cars not
gonna let it happen again let's show
that the point was if g5 oh wow they
draw but if g5 had happened
Dornish more net got to open another
analysis board guys are too fast okay
here comes the analysis don't you go
anywhere baby birds I'll feet you mama
birds here okay the point was if the
king is on d2 and okay actually we'll
just go back here in play king d2 and
and some random movies made g5 is the
idea that they were looking for with f4
and the breakthrough would allow eddie
the eagle to run home
problem is i don't think it ever worked
but kind of because of the move I just
played accidentally but this
breakthrough that Wesley was going for
with g5 was kind of the last stand it
didn't work and it is an instructive
thing to keep in mind ops compression
bendings again that you can sack as many
as you can just to get a queen and
Wesley almost had it
oh wow if if you didn't think you'd be
on the edge of your seat here with this
feat Chess Championship finals boy were
you wrong I mean I don't want to call
you out as you're you know naked on a
beanbag chair eating Cheetos but guess
what you were wrong we have a very very
close features championship and look at
hey it's like a Karl finally solved the
Italian Robert right when he needed to
yeah we've been critical if a carro
playing the Italian all day because if
you just got here he's been worse as
black in this position that they have
played you know at least a dozen times
but now he seems to have figured out
black has a very solid position
and seems to be okay here yeah it seems
to be alright right now though again
these double e Paul it's not double beep
on it at some point white may try to
play a five and break open the Queen's I
Paulo truck should use the B file for
his rooks stare down the pollen b7 so
for now it looks like they're just
shuffling back and forth Oh
d4 what a timely break saying that okay
if you can't play c4 cuz before is
hanging yep he's gonna do it well he
just didn't want the defiled open up
with two-barrel down he's gonna win it
back and the question is is b7 weaker
than a four ride the oh the open file
comes and well Queen b6 you train bees
explain 97 put it on c5 that's what we
spies that pawn with his little eye her
little eye I should say she's gonna take
it
think she takes he says shook c2 first
well she we're all the same Queen takes
b6 now a vibes coming no she wants to
keep that pawn in her sights maybe
because she has f4 in some lines yeah
this is a black just up a pawn number k5
there any rook c5 yeah I love oh he
plays for k-6 and other would be seventy
hunga spawn all route takes be 76 a4 I
just take on a forest take take Jake and
big Roberts right in the inch did Wesley
just misses work takes b7 and now he's
not gonna get another chance they're
both just they're just making blunders
here toward the end but now they're just
how was he's yeah he's losing either D 3
or a 4 or sac the exchange she finally
gets the pawn her heart desire but in
this case the outside passer is is gonna
be why blacks winning an endgame
yeah this is losing now the a pawn is
too strong
there's no attack going tonight Wow
perfectly look at that
perpetual checks are a girl's best
friend oh why can't I ever show it
because they named Queen he says just I
playing too fast Knight g5 was an idea
for a pressure will check but it didn't
work
I'm not even gonna show it but hey she
tried the Queen tried to make all the
counter play she could yep and too
little too late so okay we have this
setup once more
watch out for ever mine not even worth
saying because Queens lively coming off
you with a queen 65 you like Queen d7 or
Brooke c1 probably went first but the
cars look shocked for them
he's bad yeah
and now Hikaru is really showing why he
stays so consistent with his with his
openings this Knight f3 b3 system system
excuse me as something he's used in you
know casual bullet - you know his
streams or and then really serious
matches we've seen him do it several
years in a row in the speech Chess
Championship yeah and anytime you see
you know his b3 and I'd have to be on
the board you just have to you know know
that you're gonna be playing someone's
playing extremely quickly right your
car's putting his pieces on now he's got
95 Jack coming
ouch town population rook to c7 but 95
check does it work quite yet 95 I take
it if you say work c7 every book takes
d1 give it so what rookie 1d for Falls
what just feels so good feels so good so
nobody's gonna do it now yeah there's a
money just approved on my from t3 you
gotta do something quit 3 mg - you gotta
get e5 I liked it wasn't it eh 5 check
first what's his idea he likes trades oh
you can't take b3 Chris Bishop d6 and I
win ally so King yet I guess yeah but
now I can garden okay or trade be 4a and
I'm uppity father's play buying pawn
play Bishop c5 hit the f2 Square and you
have what you relax on the Bishop c5
idea I'll relax if you stop being creepy
okay noted Dan I still think Y can play
a three and Hikaru does it
the King has this route as well you had
to play rook a check so he didn't
blenders room yeah there was a threat
there called a double a for chemo H for
ever did that pawn yeah you should have
played h4 you may miss Murphey -
checking bishop she won oh wow but then
g4 and i guard it at least i get rid of
my double pawns rights at extra for
that's true takes takes I assume yeah
hey car is not happy bishop before it
yeah black should hold this I agree but
again it's time pressure it's bullet the
car knocking noise from the house yeah I
think the King is just getting checked
there all over the board
Oh
but these bullet games are just super
tough I mean this is this is what was
born for this
Lady Gaga le5 okay it's going after days
to pause I guess that makes more sense
change e6 was waiting for the car we
missed it but he's got Ritchie 7 but h4
was where it was at
I think a car will miss the wind with
Wesley still frustrated because he knows
it's in fact he shakes after Bishop 6
here comes my live and rook takes James
1 through 10 you owe me a coke now he's
got you five in that Rookie xh7
with check and look at Hikaru he's just
sitting tight this is this is Hikaru's
cave the bat cave welcome welcome to the
jungle
yeah it doesn't car Nakamura in the
bullet portion and it's just it's just
as fate would have it fate subscribes
and oh he mating him well in in the
words of Bane right Wesley Wesley so
came to the bullet portion right he's
trying to play in the darkness and
Bane's like I was born in it no a car
Nakamura is like welcome to bullet I was
born in it I mean this is literally his
his territory welcome to the jungle that
was a draw as you said black should've
held with best play but it just seemed
to work the work right yeah well ok
Wesley is it's not out of it yet 10
minutes with a three minute three-game
lead is the biggest one we've had in the
match so far for Hikaru but it may be
all he needs if Wesley doesn't strike
now right so and was vision is great
here right you can just take on cc1
first I have even better the point is
that this pawn if he goes see for the 96
happens you're traveling now it's a free
pawn on c5
so this is not looking very good for a
car but it wasn't used to put him away
you can't just be better in a position
you need to actually win the games so
chat out you the only bring in the 5000
bits I'd like to think it was for my
Bain impression
probably was nights before bishops
developed them your Tom Hardy being
impression was very good but no
seriously I mean we we know this is what
a carnal kamar is capable of and and
Wesley so has played such great chess
today but now now you have to find it in
Bullitt or it's all over
c67 no c6 Bishop c7 huh the car is just
trying to get encountered played but
okay this game he's come back right now
I mean White's better here so this is
Wesley's game right now but time is
ticking yes about two asking for a 4 B 5
a 5 here ok this is nice because you
want to passers you never want one pass
pawn and obstinate bishops because one
pass pawn can be blockaded but if you
can get the 2 over here but look at her
car oh he's bouncing because he knows he
figured it out he's gonna force the
pawns to dark squares and it's gonna be
a draw
silly hikaru blockades are for kids
CC snow b6 doesn't work b6 just taking
on c5 okay the car was pausing people he
knows he knows he's got it he's got the
blockade in fact maybe black can turn
this one around because those problems
are blockaded but blacks pawns are not
yeah this bishop is kind of uh looking a
little lost over here yeah just for the
f5
ok but I can never lose but yeah I mean
you know office wait what you just want
to trap that bishop in there I guess
trapping the bishop permanently for all
time and space look at Wesley inch
worming his way back into the fold but
as you said okay I maybe I spoke too
soon is it black and why can never lose
but he caught a rush and Freddie yeah
just have Freddie will not become
Francis today though he has been
blockaded and no Queens happening but a
car looking I'm just cleaning up all the
pawns Plus this is from a match strategy
this is almost gg because hey karo if he
really wants to go full gamesmanship and
just play tickle here and it take
another minute a half on the clock right
the total game clock is running yep he's
gonna keep pre moving and waiting for
are we gonna see a bomb cloud will we
see a pawn cloud we've been asked hey
Cora Nakamura has been has been
did by his fans Sakura Nakamura will
also be having a 24-hour stream at some
point in December because he made a
regretful promise that if he reached a
thousand subs he'd do a 24 hour stream
no no he's gonna do a 24 hour stream he
was already talking to me about it last
night but as we said he can take a lot
of time off the clock and that's what
he's doing to ensure victory and we'll
see whether that means he has time for a
bong cloud or not you're wondering we
are not talking about any sort of
paraphernalia of any kind if this is a
family friendly show the bong cloud is
an opening and the odds of the bong
caught have gone way up I predicted it
would not happen I was wrong
maybe we'll see but Wesley has played
more than well enough to today to kind
of avoid that but having lost a few in a
row and bullet-head karo may now be
within the realm of knowing he's got the
species championship title locked up
yeah I could feel you next to me you
tensed up a little bit which is so cute
by the way you tense up when you're
nervous it's a door I wasn't nervous
this wasn't paying attention because
they were just shuffling back and forth
yeah and all the same just once you know
how cute that was over a minute I told
you I told it another 90 seconds could
come off that was so good and then the
car was thinking again is it not a draw
yeah look how much time they have you
can't just go oh this is so great it
gorges free moves Wesley Wesley turns
words like are you think are you kidding
me right now oh my god that was
legendary stuff right there yep any cars
gonna take on b5 and pre move again
watch water time hey gonna be five and
then pre move 50 moves here goes here
goes let's just pre move because now
we've reset 50 moves he's good all
Wesley's shouldn't have given him the
bishop oh my god if Wesley had kept the
bishop if he had kept the bishop it
would have been a 50 move if you don't
know you have a 50 move rule draw in
chess if there's been no progress made
which is either a capture or an on push
that's how we
your progress in chess and Wesley gave
him the bishop so he screwed up and
that's why he Cara pause wise it was he
just doing the same thing pre move stop
wasting time was he I don't think he
even knows it's his movie like he's just
sorted laughing he's probably really
annoyed this is it's good games which
absolutely bananas this is so good the
car just took one bullet game from eight
minutes left to four minutes left I mean
do you feel like we just watched our
game pac-man oh my god I can't take it
oh my god this is so good Carswell so
again some people have like complained
about what the dynamic is here that it's
like let's force majeure whatever but
the truth is we've already seen several
people do this we've seen Magnus do it
we've seen Griffith do it we've seen a
carro do it many times this beat chess
championship format is honestly really
special and obviously I'm biased you
know that but it is it's very special
because it creates these opportunities
for for the players to use the game
clock against their opponent which is
something you do in other sports the NBA
the NFL right well you don't get mad at
a quarterback when he takes a knee and
runs out the clock instead of throwing
an interception do you you don't get mad
in the NBA when they dribble out and let
the shot clock go and that's really what
it is here it's a match situation that
they're leveraging and using against
their opponents so everyone chats going
crazy I'm trying to catch up here but
yeah yeah and that was that was if
someone just said that was worth the
$50,000 prize for the hakarl just locked
up the championship with that right
there and somebody goes out of his way
to create a bond cloud username and
kitty-kitty hiss hiss never misses a
beat we love that guy
instantly donating a sub so Wow well
again if you're with us right now one of
the 20,000 viewers not only was that
amazing but don't go anywhere because we
are about to have both these players
join us in three minutes at this point I
think we can safely call it because
mathematically Hikaru Nakamura just
ensured himself the victory with that
incredible show of highly clippable
moments and that was a good laugh I
needed that yeah I will say though you
know says the dealer question is the
format I for one I'm not the biggest fan
of that
think I don't like that in basketball
right you know you can just you but
they're fouls right there's something
you can do right well the people that
are down on on on the scoreboard can
foul right to try to get the ball back
right which is another and people
complain about the fouling right that's
at least gives a team that's losing a
chance in right in this format there's
you've no chance there's nothing you can
just sits for a minute on the clock so
true
true but again I mean it's it's part of
the overall match strategy that you
wouldn't be able to do right if you
weren't winning and also I think that
Wesley made a pretty funny show of it by
actually giving up the bishop it was
funny the DiCaro had the presence of
mind to pause when the bishop was
hanging and wait for it wow it was just
crazy
so yeah and I'm not saying it is the
most is it the most traditional way to
win a chess match no but but it
certainly has been tried and pretty
funny moment there whew he didn't play
the bong cloud though and he may have
missed his chance because this might be
the last time he gets the white pieces
and I don't blame your car for doing
that right it's in the rules you do it
you take advantage of it absolutely same
thing with Magnus right we were upset
and I was upset how the draw was made
for a spectator reasons yep I cannot
blame Magnus we're taking to wrap it
against Bobby I don't where he was just
a much stronger rapid player so yep
yeah was the unfortunate it seems like
one of our lowest scoring matches ever I
think we've had scores similar to this
and history but no this is it's right
there right they haven't played a lot of
games wake our faces this before then
why I missed it I was actually looking
at the board there we switched roles
yeah there you go
yep well yeah like I said we will have
interviews here with the players in just
a moment I think one of the interesting
storylines of course is the Italian
write both sides and what happened there
I think obviously we've got Wesley who
just it barely got away from him and
bullet and Hikaru didn't look back but
we'll have some Exynos if you have
questions for the players ask them now
so we can read and and get some
questions okay well if you have some
useful ones and this game is over
because age weight they drew they play
another rule agreement
well I would have just looked the timer
another fiery car but I guess he's
already won the match so he might as
well kick he might he's not gonna get
one more white no he has to purposely
lose oh you gonna play the bugs out with
black it was the first time we've ever
have you ever seen the bond cloud with
black I don't think so
okay well Hikaru makes do on his promise
to his fans that's why he took the draw
that's why you took the draw so we could
get one more game yes classic classic
well it it has been Hikaru's speech
Chess Championship this 2018 and you
know both some of the most hilarious
most exciting and you know ultimately
winning the event as far as all the
moments that he's brought us so we're
obviously gonna be joined by both the
players Wesley so had an amazing event
this year as well and for a I mean I
honestly was on the edge of my seat as
to whether or so could play the way he
did against Duda yeah and and and win
this match here because people have just
said it's like it's the car was matched
right to win and and we were tied
heading into bullet if you happen to
only just be getting here it was 10 to
10 before a car Nakamura separated
himself in the final portion so
incredible match we will be joined by
both players in just a moment
right after this bond cloud from black
yeah it was he will likely be a bit
frustrated because of course as a chess
player he wants to win the games over
they just true so there you go should be
joining with a nice draw by mutual
agreement another two thousand bits
there from chess BAE yep thank you so
much we are gonna take a very quick
break get our sound check and video
check on with the players and we will
have interviews in just a few moments
you right back
[Music]
and we are now back with our two players
with us for interviews and can I just
say on behalf of myself Robert and all
the fans that are here you guys gave us
quite the match today it takes two to
tango and this was a masterpiece of a
show I mean seriously it was so exciting
back and forth and ultimately of course
congratulations to you Hikaru you have
won that the 2018 speeches championship
Wesley if we had told you you were tied
10 to 10 with a carro headed into bullet
which you have taken that ahead of time
you know it's hard to say I mean it
probably at the disadvantage because
once the shorter the time control the
bigger he carves advantage gets right
and well before the match I would be I
was hoping maybe I could try to get some
lead the five minutes or the three
minutes because I know once I pulled it
comes right and it's very hard to
control the situation and see you can
see from the match once the bullet game
starts I think a car just played
fantastically and I didn't even realize
I was down by two points
but Mr Pibb silly enter kindly reminded
me so yeah I think I just I'm just
playing too slow and the bullet I mean
it's very hard to compete against he on
in that regard and congratulations in
for winning this the speed chess
championship no what was your strategy
coming into the match of course your
bullet prowess was on full display but
did you have any number of specific
numbers in mind how close here to keep
the match in order to just become the
favored heading it to the bullet yeah I
mean general I felt that if I keep that
was in about two points if I'm not down
more than two I think I have very good
chances and pull it
I mean Wesley played much better than I
did pretty much for the first I would
say two hours meeting a little more than
that and then he got careless and this
one game was wider please it's like
night after a d3 cheater he got a little
bit careless then once I won that game
thanks her to turn around but I mean I
think I was quite lucky with that well
one of the overarching story lines of
the of the match was your guys's
consistency your persistence to play the
Italian
Ricardo you said yesterday in the match
with LaVon that you were prepared to
play the Italian positions or you
thought you might get that if I remember
correctly and today you stuck with it
despite the fact that it seemed that for
the first 90 minutes as you said it felt
like Wesley was really getting some
great positions as white but your
persistence paid off because toward the
end you actually seemed like you solved
it can you talk a little bit about what
was the Italian something you expected
to get as black here and did you
purposely kind of stick with it despite
getting some tough positions because it
eventually kind of paid off and you were
doing okay as black yeah the thing is
kind of the where I was playing which I
thought was not great it would have been
a little bit risky to try and play
something a little bit less solid and
more aggressive because I just wasn't
playing well I mean you even saw it I
mean it was three minutes I mean Wesley
wondered this piece with this b5 and
Queen d5 PG 5 any other then I still
made a blunder right back and so like
just in general is quite tough but I
felt it just made sense to stay slow and
it wasn't good enough that that's just
how it goes mostly served wet right but
wisely
over to you then did you think you would
get an Italian game against a car oh you
you had a very consistent approach there
as well and seem to be doing getting
decent positions as white throughout the
whole bliss portion what what did you
prepare if anything for her Caro and was
the Italian something you thought you'd
get I went coming to the match I didn't
think that we'd say anything theoretical
but I look at kickers match against the
one yesterday and I know they said they
were playing a lots of pain lines you
know Victor was playing the Berlin with
moat colors and he was playing the main
line with gambit which I didn't really
expect so yeah for this match I assumed
that he would say the same openings and
you know I decided to go for this
Italian without the Bishop g5 because
yesterday Lebon was getting these very
complicated positions and it wasn't it
was getting very complicated so I've
latest white lines
and see how it goes
I think in the first two games I was
pleased with the position I was getting
which were not very complex and a little
bit risk-free so I mean I could play
other moves on the first
well but I wasn't sure what petitions I
was getting at least here in the Italian
I can play my first 15 moves before
thinking right and yeah in the end it I
think I miss played it you know Oh in
the bull in the bullet section also in
the two-minute section my night was
going to c4 then back to ETF 1gt I
should have gone right away to f1 and
kicker was out playing me in the end in
the Italian so I switch to nitrous to
eating but as he said it takes two to
tango so if he didn't mind saying the
Italian then and then why not right well
you mentioned openings and the dakara
was playing theory with LaVon and so you
thought he might do the similar thing
here but but back to you a car oh we've
highlighted that this Knight f3 b3
system is something you play a lot you
play it in your on your streams you play
in in bullet matches we made a chest bra
reference right in because you know
those positions so well it's a little
different than main line Theory
objectively maybe why it doesn't get the
greatest middle games but you're able to
play so fast in those positions is that
just something you have as an overall
approach to bullet that you consistently
try to reach those positions where even
if even if it's roughly equal you know
what the plans are better than your
opponent so you can play faster and out
calculate them yeah I mean in general
the reason for that is just avoid theory
basically just make it where you have to
find that moves really quickly and so I
I'm probably going to keep doing that I
don't I mean I think I'm bullet to play
like me and lines a little bit silly I
mean I guess I have this one game
against Maxime where we play sound like
25 moves in Berlin which was kind of
ridiculous but you know I think in
general in bullet you just have to play
good news play on intuition I think you
want positions where you just you just
kind of find moves suppose like
calculating anything the problem also it
fitting against a car in in little time
controls it's that a car is very good
not only in complex and complicated
positions but also in end games so I
have to choose the least of to eat this
or I go for some
positioned and under beef that's always
they should like like in India Hagar and
I played this end game
remember when you were white and I its
job tonight on game yeah I thought I
would get Afridi but there was much
harder than that well you're very
complimentary of Vacarro and obviously
Wesley you play very well yourself today
as Hikaru said right I mean for the
first couple hours and it was honestly
just absolutely thrilling it was amazing
all we could hope for
I only have one more question but I'm
gonna let you go before my last question
was West because you watched the match
yesterday did you think you might get a
bong cloud if you got it if in the last
game we saw you had a big smile on a car
oh you merely worked it in with that
draw you agreed to and then played it as
black we thought you weren't gonna get
it for me well I guess if you thought
you'd get it you saw him play to get me
one I mean what's the thickness if you
go online you google the bong cloud
opening you'll understand this is
there's like a 20 page PDF file online
which is completely crazy it was by a
madman but yeah it seems like I moved
that you would say against against
Komodo right right if you don't match in
the in the future you can you know the
play and upon down there I like that car
overseas Komodo bong cloud or you versus
the Komodo ball cloud that's a great
idea anyway well thank you both
seriously this has been an amazing and
amazing way to bring this event to a
close and congratulations the car one
more time on taking on the top prize
Wesley congratulations on such an
amazing performance today and very very
close and just I think the fans got all
they could have asked for so we
appreciate you both we're gonna say a
few more words before signing off but
we'll let you go and thank you guys
thank you alright well as we said the
prizes on the line today were 5,000 to
the winter and then games split by
winning percentage so not bad for a
three-hour blitz match and
congratulations again to both these guys
and they're just
they were very complimentary of each
other and nice to have them an interview
on here you have it and come our
Nakamura atop a tall everyone there at
the end the overall one seat takes at
home in the speech Chess Championship
and we still 15,000 of you with us so
thank you for still being here Robert
your final thoughts reflecting on this
specific match after we talked a little
bit about the protest League so January
8th you and I will have the call I think
right on that day with some other hosts
we will announce soon but the protest
League is coming up your favorite team
logo ooh I really like the Barcelona
Raptors
that's all that's a new one yeah that's
a new team I saw that when it was put in
the drop box yeah I mean the Moscow
Wizards look at that one
that's the Moscow Wizards it's scary
that's a very East sport esque and like
you know is that League of Legends or
you know I I don't know but I also I
also like just some of the classics you
know I like the gnomes one this classic
one yeah that's been around for a long
time so the San Francisco mechanics
would be led by Sam Shanklin the st.
Louis Archbishop's led by either Wesley
so or Fabiano Caruana you take your pick
of who you think is leading them Seattle
is led by that guy who just won this V
chess championship so we know who their
favorite isn't as we said Fabiano
playing down I almost think they're led
by Wesley cuz Wesley
won the MVP in 2017 of returning but at
one-two combination is hard to beat
unless you got that guy on board I'm
gonna win the MVP last year he did
actually right so st. Louis is boasting
both MVPs remind you you can actually
pick up limited item in our merch store
if you want approached us like backpack
go fall equip cold your mouse over the
screen right now and you can follow the
pro chesley channel obviously we're
hyping it because it's kind of our our
baby coming up here we're gonna be
really excited about everything we have
in store coming up in the 2019 season
again mark your calendars January 8th is
when it all begins but before we let you
go wish everybody an absolutely
wonderful holiday season safe regardless
of how you choose to celebrate the
holidays keep it safe keep it frame
family friendly unless you're watching
my streams in that case no
family-friendly stuff allowed definitely
not but it's been great dude I got to
send you home
we won't hug it out or any kind of out
on camera don't cry you know but Roberts
mom is waiting for him and we're sending
you back to the Big Apple yep
it's been the world chess championship
the speed chess championship and huge
thanks to everybody that's just been
with us and and watched our our coverage
throughout the entire month of November
and I know you're like what is that I'm
here for the speech as you're talking
with the world's chess championship but
it's all been one you know one big long
ride a big party and last bits they're
really really appreciate everybody who's
tuned in and anything you want to say
there I know you waiting me to let you
go I just don't want to let you go
let's yak well never let go look at
those candles in the water I'll get down
low oh you know I'll get down if that's
what you want me to do and you can kind
of like Holt you'll be you'll be rose
[Laughter]
I'm going with things half the time
that's why I have to pivot
mid-conversation a lot of the time
you're gonna be Ross I start hibbott I
start speaking before I've thought about
what I should be saying anyway we love
you all thank you chess BAE thank you
all of our mods I'm gonna I'm gonna
shout them out cuz I cuz I got a list of
um chess pay nine for manna for coffee
and tea we love the party bjh won three
in the time of nick mentioning him just
in the nick of time
deejay chest dog wicka wicka frank Rutan
andy goon recruiter and NJ greg
everybody over at the chest TV chat and
the live chess game chat as well shout
out to our in our producer who's been
holding it down and making everything as
awesome as it could possibly be the
speeches championship is over I'm so
glad there are no more official events
in December I got a I'm not gonna lie
yeah I'm ready for the break I know
you're ready for the break from our
break you ready for the break we were on
a break we were on a break
Ross vs Rachel was the break official
get out us on Twitter let us know what
you think we're gonna let you go right
now and see you at next year's features
championship and see you on January 8
for the protest league peace
[Music]
[Applause]